Hallo Leute, ich bin wieder am Start.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei euch.
Fällt mir nur gerade so ein, weil der Krieger bei mir aufgeploppt ist in der Empfehlungsliste gerade vor 10 Sekunden.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Oder wie ging das?
Da gab es schon richtige Cringe-Sachen damals.
Ich sage nur die Commander Krieger-Wauzis, Alter.
Das ist wirklich Dice of Cringe-Time, ey.
Sgt. Silver, danke für den Sub.
Ach ja, ich kann euch übrigens winken kurz.
Moment, da muss ich aber umschalten.
Guck mal hier.
Chatke.
Hä?
Was ist das denn für 3 FPS Webcam, Alter?
1, 2, 3 FPS.
Wobei, jetzt geht's?
Ich habe mittlerweile eine GoPro am Start.
Die wollte ich eigentlich hierfür verwenden.
Aber das Ding per USB anzuschließen ist ja schon wieder der übelste Abfuck, ey.
Handlieg.
Monka.
W.
Es ist etwas zu sehr Sleepge die Musik, würde ich sagen, oder?
Ja.
Auch Sleepge-Musik.
Okay.
Geht.
Hör mal auf.
Also.
Ich habe versucht meine GoPro anzuschließen.
Ich habe jetzt hier oben das iPhone wieder dran, da oben.
Guck mal, ich habe gar nicht mehr so dicke Arme wie früher.
Seht ihr das?
Lul.
Weight Loss Champ hier.
Weight Loss Champ.
7 LQRS, danke für den Sub.
Warum nicht?
Ach, das ist Gaming-Musik.
Das ist schon okay.
Was du nicht abspielen darfst, ist...
Was ist denn so Mainstream gerade?
So Mainstream-Pop-Shit und sowas.
Oder generell.
Generell halt so kommerzielle Musik.
So.
Du kannst auch nicht Metallica abspielen oder sowas.
Was ist das?
Äh, das ist das Schild.
Das da?
Das ist, glaube ich, das Schild von...
Von ein paar Handschuhen?
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist das Schild von ein paar Handschuhen.
Ja, ja.
Metallica claimt quasi proaktiv.
Bevor du überhaupt die Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hast,
sind die schon am claimen.
Es gibt...
Nur Apple ist noch schneller im Claim als Metallica.
Ne, ich benutze kein Intune.
Gibt's auch Abmahnungen auf Twitch?
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, Abmahnungen sind relativ selten.
Aber es gibt Copyright-Strikes.
Meiner ist wieder weg.
Apple hat sich's wieder anders überlegt.
Das hat Silver, danke für den Sub, gar nicht gesehen.
Ja, wir müssen nicht großartig...
Großartigen Lötschamp machen heute.
Also, wir müssen im Endeffekt nur...
Ihr seht ja auch, es ist ganz schön staubig hier geworden.
Ich hab lange, lange hier den Kram nicht mehr benutzt.
Hier das Bastel-Streaming-Setup.
Also, ich hab hier meine GoPro am Start.
Aber das hier oben ist noch ein iPhone, weil...
Ich hab mir vorhin angeguckt, wie man die GoPro in OBS bringt.
Ist eigentlich relativ simpel.
Software installieren und per USB anstöpseln.
Wobei ich nicht verstehe, warum man unbedingt eine extra...
Eine extra Software braucht.
Warum meldet sich die GoPro nicht einfach an per USB,
wie sie sich normal gehört, wie eine Kamera.
Aber dann ist mir aufgefallen,
um die GoPro wireless irgendwie an den Rechner zu bringen,
da müsste man noch irgendwie zig Zusatzsoftware...
Da hatte ich keinen Bock mit...
Null Bock mich mit auseinanderzusetzen.
Deswegen hab ich jetzt einfach hier wieder oben das...
Das iPhone dran gemacht.
Auch wenn es...
Irgendwie...
Leichtes Gelegge teilweise hat.
Vielleicht liegt das aber auch hier dran.
Sekunde, ich probier mal was.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich mach eh keine superschnellen Bewegungen.
Ja.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, warte mal.
Wo ist er denn?
Das nächste Problem war...
Das nächste Problem war, die GoPro hat ja diesen komischen...
Diesen komischen Dings hier oben.
Diesen...
Dieses GoPro Ding halt.
Dieses GoPro.
Und ich hab keine Halterung, die...
Hier oben an den...
An die Halterung passt.
Also ich hab zwar jede Menge solcher GoPro Halterung an sich,
aber keine GoPro Halterung, die hier an dieses komische Gelenk
von dem Ring Light dran passt.
Deswegen hab ich gedacht, bevor ich da jetzt ewig rumbastel,
lass ich's bleiben und mach einfach wieder das iPhone dran.
Und gut, das...
Ja.
Ja, das iPhone, das Fokus teilweise so doof hier.
Guck, seht ihr das so?
Das denkt immer so, oh, ich muss Fokus-Champ machen.
Klingt nach einem Job fürs 3D-Drucken.
Näh.
3D-Drucker kriegst ja keine Metallkugel irgendwie da oben hin.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie ich das gescheit mach.
Das...
Ich...
Ich glaub, die GoPro...
Gerade wenn ich die per USB anschließe, müsste schon noch ein bisschen angenehmer sein,
als mit dem iPhone.
Aber für die 5 Minuten, wo wir jetzt gleich was löten,
draufgeschissen.
Äh...
Der hat aber...
Der hat aber kein ZigBee, oder?
Ach, der hat auch ZigBee?
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem H2
und...
dem C6?
Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Der Preis!
Ah...
Der hat kein WiFi, der H2, oder?
Der hat nur ZigBee.
Nichts ist richtig?
Wart mal...
Cheat!
Also nicht Cheat, sondern...
Cheat.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ne, Bluetooth hat er dabei.
Also Bluetooth...
An...
Scheint...
Ne, kein WiFi.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur blöd geschrieben.
Du kannst Bluetooth und ZigBee da...
Okay, der...
Okay, der H2 hat kein WiFi.
Es ist langsam ziemlich undurchsichtig, die ESP32-Chip-Familie, so was es da alles gibt.
Und...
ich war und dann haben die angefangen mit esp 32 s123 c6 h2 und was nicht alles
gibt und da da habe ich bin ich ausgestiegen
das war mir dann echt zu viel es war mal kleine kleine löt champ action dass wir
das hinter uns haben ich habe den guck mich das jetzt
gescheit macht dass ich hier was sehe weil ich habe ich habe keinen forscher
und die forscher habe ich nur nur hier gucken wir mal wie gut das funktioniert
also im prinzip müssen wir folgendes machen das ist sehr eigentlich massive
massive und zwar wir müssen ein temperatursensor hier dran löten und
jetzt nicht über 3 mich will den wieder abkriegen danach ja das ist jetzt nur
mal zum testen witzigerweise ich habe mir so ein paar
pins gekauft so stecke so steckpins
die ich jetzt leider auf die schnelle nicht mehr finde
somit hätte ich die man mal ausprobieren können wo habe ich die denn die hier
sind keiner ich habe acht doch guck mal oder nicht
ich habe immer so ein set solcher steckstecker按liche heißt diese dinge
dann so pins zum reinstecken gekauft dass man das nicht festMadonna last
aber ich habe keine ahnung wo ich die hingeschmissen habe die tilgq
liegen ganz dran
Garantiert in irgendeiner Ecke und so.
Deswegen, wir machen jetzt einfach mal schnell hier ein paar Pins.
Das ist das Dumme.
Ich sehe wieder nicht richtig was.
Aber ich denke doch.
So sehe ich eigentlich was ganz gut, glaube ich.
Ja, zumindest.
Oh, bevor wir, ich sehe es gerade.
Bevor wir anfangen, Löt-Champ zu machen,
ich muss unbedingt die andere Spitze drauf machen,
weil die ist so klein.
Die ist wirklich nur für ganz kleines,
feines Zeug.
Ihr seht ja, wie dünn die ist.
Ah, das iPhone kann mal wieder nicht richtig fokussieren.
Guck mal, wie dünn die ist.
Also, damit hast du kaum richtige
so Wärmeübertragung.
Dann nehme ich lieber wieder die normale.
Die ist so ein bisschen fetter.
Ich bräuchte so ein Zwischending, so zwischen der fetten.
Ich habe doch, Moment, ich habe irgendwo auch noch eine.
Aber so in meiner Ordnung,
ihr wisst, wie es ist, ja.
Hier habe ich noch eine.
Die ist ein bisschen,
ein bisschen größer.
Finde wieder nichts.
Und in meiner Lötkiste
liegt irgendwie ein abgeschnittenes USB-Kabel.
Ich weiß nicht, was.
Was das da macht.
Naja.
Wir machen das jetzt mal schnell dran.
Eine Runde Löt-Champ und dann machen wir weiter.
Also, mein Plan ist,
für alle, die das letzte Mal
nicht dabei waren oder die das
in den letzten Streams nicht mitgekriegt haben.
Leon, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, mein Plan ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir
ein paar ESP
82,
äh, nicht 82,
32, 82, das gibt es.
Ein paar ESP 32 C6 besorgt.
Also, hier solche, solche Dinger.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie es aus der Verpackung kommt,
weil da ist kaum was drin.
Die haben, also diese Boards hier,
die sind
ziemlich gut bestückt
an Features
und an allem, was man so braucht, um ein
ESP 32 Projekt
umzusetzen, was man an eine Batterie hängen kann.
Die Batterien habe ich übrigens mittlerweile auch gefunden.
Also, ich muss sagen, ich habe,
ich habe mal vor einer Weile aufgeräumt.
Und habe das alles in so, guck, ihr seht es hier.
Ich habe die ganzen Komponenten, die ich habe, in so,
in so Förmchen einsortiert.
Was ich nicht gemacht habe, ich habe nichts vorne drauf gedruckt oder so.
Aber man kann ja, man kann, im Schrank kann man ja durchgucken und sieht ja, was drin ist.
Und da habe ich jetzt innerhalb von zwei Minuten tatsächlich die Temperatursensoren gefunden und die Batterie.
Wobei, die Batterie brauchen wir nicht, wir schließen das Ding jetzt erstmal per USB an.
Naja, zumindest, die Boards haben richtig nice Features.
Und zwar, ich packe einfach nochmal eins von denen aus, dass man sieht, was da drin ist.
Also, es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Kostet, wenn man es in Deutschland bestellt, 9,95 Euro.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, wenn man das von DF Droid Robot in den, ich glaube, USA oder UK bestellt,
ist es wahrscheinlich nochmal eine Ecke billiger.
Aber da muss man dann wahrscheinlich, dass es sich lohnt mit dem Versand,
eh, auch mal irgendwie 10 oder so bestellen.
Zumindest das Coolste.
Zumindest das Coole an dem Board ist, dass es sehr stromsparend ist.
Also, perfekt für Batterie-Projekte geeignet.
Warum kein Pico?
Habe ich auch hier, aber der hat, der hat kein ZigBee.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwie möglich ist, dass man ZigBee dran kriegt an den Raspberry Pi.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Add-On-Module oder so gibt.
Kein, kein Schimmer.
Zumindest, der hat alles on Board.
Also, ich zeige mal, was, was da alles dabei ist in der Packung.
Es hält sich wirklich ganz hart in Grenzen.
Im Prinzip gibt es da nur eine Plastik, eine Plastiktüte mit dem Board drinnen
und zwei Pinheader.
Fertig.
Also, die Verpackung hätte man sich fast sparen können.
Und das alles in irgend so eine recycelbare Papiertüte reinschmeißen und gut ist.
Aber so ist es.
So sieht es auch aus.
Also, im Prinzip gibt es das Board, zwei Pinheader.
Fertig.
Keine Spirenzchen.
Nichts irgendwie Advancedes.
Auch keine, was ich ein bisschen, was ich ja persönlich immer cool finde ist,
gibt es aber wenig Hersteller, die das machen, wenn man Color-Coded Pinheader hat.
Ja.
Also, weil es ist ja so, wenn man diesen Pinheader jetzt beispielsweise hier dran macht,
der übrigens witzigerweise, der zu lang ist für das Board.
Auch geil.
Ist der andere kurz.
Okay, man kann die easy abbrechen, ja.
Aber, ja.
Okay, die sind alle ein bisschen zu lang für das Board.
Da hat man wirklich das Billigstmögliche gewählt, wie man das macht.
Aber das ist kein Ding.
Die kann man hier einfach abknipsen und dann passen sie.
Aber ich brauche die, ich brauche die eh gerade nicht.
Ich meine, wir könnten auch einen Pinheader dran machen.
Da können wir die Sachen vielleicht einfacher dran schöpseln.
Aber die haben überhaupt keine richtigen Anschlüsse dafür.
Zumindest, was ich ja immer ganz cool finde, wenn die Hersteller Pinheader mit Color-Coding so drauf liefern.
Weil, man sieht es hier vielleicht.
Ich hoffe, man erkennt es, wenn ich es nah genug dran halte.
Guckt mal.
Die Pins, oder vielleicht lege ich das da drauf.
Dann erkennt man es vielleicht besser.
Erkennt man, dass die Pins unterschiedliche Beschriftungen haben und was da dran steht?
Ja, ich glaube, erkennt man, ne?
Ja, da hat man zum Beispiel einen Pin für Ground, einen für 3,3 Volt und sowas in der Richtung.
Und ich finde es immer cool, wenn die Hersteller Pinheader mitliefern,
die zumindest Ground und 3,3 Volt oder auch 5, je nachdem, was die Boards alles für einen Ausgang haben.
Ich meine, 5 haben die ja meistens nur, wenn sie per USB angeschlossen sind.
Wenn es dann hier zumindest mal irgendwie so einen roten und einen schwarzen Pinheader und so gibt.
Das finde ich immer nice.
Naja, ich mache das mal weg.
Was wir da jetzt machen ist,
wir schnappen uns so einen dieser Temperatursensoren.
Das sind...
DS18B20.
Das ist so der Feld, Wald und Wiesen.
Man sieht, dass du Sport machst.
Ja, ich habe doch auch schon gesagt.
Guckt mal, Leute, meine Arme.
Meine Arme sind gar nicht mehr so fett wie früher.
Max, deine Hände sehen mittlerweile so attraktiv aus.
Cup of Pride.
Also ich finde auch, dass meine Finger, wenn sie nicht so dick sind, besser aussehen wie dick.
Zumindest das hier sind DS18B20.
Das sind so die 0815 Temperatursensoren.
Temperatursensoren, die es gibt.
Ihr habt es ja gesehen, so sehen die Dinger aus.
Vom Anschluss her easy as fuck.
Ground.
Meine Kabel sind gelb, rot und schwarz.
Was auch immer das ist.
Ja, so.
Also im Prinzip muss man den einmal an 3,3 Volt anschließen an Ground und an einen GPIO. Fertig.
Ich habe die Dinger auch schon ausgelesen.
An einem ESP32 mit dem Standard Arduino Zeug drauf.
Mal gucken, wie das mit ESP-EDF funktioniert.
Ich meine, wir haben ja das Arduino Plugin.
Wir können auch Arduino Libraries benutzen.
Den Widerstand, den sparen wir uns mal.
Weil die GPIO Pins selber, die kann man auf Pull-Up stellen.
Und ich glaube, dann brauchen wir das nicht.
Das ist ja im Prinzip ein Pull-Up, wenn man so will.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe von Dings hier auf VCC.
Ja.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Also wir löten das Ding dran.
Und dann machen wir Proggastells und gucken, wie wir den Kram ansprechen können.
Aber vorher, bevor ich Twitter mit dieser viel zu kleinen Spitze anfange, tauche ich den Kram erstmal schnell aus.
Wie macht man das?
Ich habe es schon ewig nicht mehr gewechselt.
Ich glaube jetzt, es geht nicht mehr raus.
Ah, ich bin doof.
Ich muss das gar nicht raus machen.
Guck mal, da ist auch unten sowas dran schon.
Und jetzt einfach hier rein und drehen.
Easy.
Okay, das ist einfach.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich mir dieses Teil gekauft habe.
Das ist echt nice.
Also, wenn es interessiert, kein Sellout und nichts.
Muss man ein bisschen das Stau überhaupt machen, weil das staubig ist.
Das hier ist eine Ersa.
Ja, da sieht man uns.
Icon Nano Lötstation.
Und das nice an dem Ding ist, der Lötkolben, also man hat hier noch so eine, die zeige ich euch aber nicht, weil die ist staubig as fuck.
So eine Halterung für den Lötkolben, also kann man hier reinstecken.
Zumindest, was ich an der halt wirklich nice finde, dass das so ein flexibles Kabel ist am Lötkolben.
Also sprich, du kannst hier auch wirklich ganz komische Kurven machen und das funktioniert immer noch.
Und es ist halt sehr leicht.
Das sind nicht diese riesen Prügel an Lötkolben, die man direkt an die Steckdose anschließt, die es für 12,50 Euro beim Aldi gibt.
Sondern ein bisschen teurer, aber das hat sich echt gelohnt.
Also, ich muss sagen, ich habe das Teil bestimmt schon fünf Jahre oder so oder länger.
Und ich habe noch nie so viel gelötet wie damit.
Es macht, weil es Bock macht.
Ich will kurz was trinken.
Ach ja, genau.
Was ich noch sagen wollte zu dem Board.
Also man sieht, man hat enorm viele, enorm viele GPIO Anschlüsse.
Plus, man hat ein paar Crown Pins und ein paar 3,3 Volt Pins.
Aber was halt richtig cool ist, das erste ist USB-C.
Also man sieht, dass das in der ESP32 etwas neuere Bauart ist.
USB-C.
Dann hast du hier neben die üblichen Knöpfe.
Also hier, wenn das iPhone das auf die Reihe kriegt.
Einen Reset-Knopf und einen Boot-Knopf.
Der Boot-Knopf ist dafür, wenn man mal aus Versehen irgendeine Firmware draufflasht, die kaputt ist.
Die beispielsweise sich immer neu startet oder falsche GPIOs konfiguriert hat und was auch immer.
Und man kommt nicht mehr per Konsole hier USB dran, weil man irgendwas so verkackt hat, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Dann kann man den Boot-Knopf gedrückt halten und Reset drücken.
Und dann bootet das in so einem temporären Bootloader-Modus.
Wo man nichts anderes machen kann als flashen.
Deswegen ist es nice, dass das Board die zwei Knöpfe hat.
Dann hat man hier, glaube ich...
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was das hier ist?
Ich glaube, das ist für ESP32-Kameras der Anschluss.
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Ob irgendjemand von euch mal ESP32-Cam gemacht hat oder so.
Ich nie.
Ich glaube, das ist der Kameraanschluss hier oben.
Ach ja, Leute.
Ich habe selbstverständlich natürlich mein Anti-Static-Halsband.
Genau.
An.
Mein Anti-Static-Halsband.
Kann gar nichts passieren.
Also, es muss ja das Halsband sein, weil an den Fingern habe ich es...
Ja, an den Händen habe ich es nicht.
Nee, ich gebe zu, ich habe nichts an.
Aber selbst, wenn ich das Board kaputt mache, dann ist es halt kaputt.
Ja.
So.
Und das eigentliche Coole an dem Board ist, du hast Bluetooth dabei.
Zigbee dabei.
WLAN dabei.
Leider nur 2,4 GHz.
Kein 5 GHz WLAN.
Obwohl die Wifi 6 unterstützen.
Unterstützen sie kein 5 GHz.
Da hatten wir es heute Morgen von.
Ich weiß nicht, was die China-Chinesen dabei gedacht haben.
Zumindest ziemlich beknackt.
Aber es ist leider so.
Meines Wissens nach hat Espressif keinen Controller am Start, der 5 GHz WLAN unterstützt.
Man kann das natürlich sagen.
Wozu?
Ja, ist eigentlich egal.
Das Ding hat so geringe Datenraten und sind wirklich notwendig.
Naja.
Ich glaube, es ist eigentlich egal.
Ich kann dazu sagen, manchmal sind die 2,4 GHz Frequenzen so voll, dass es sicherlich
nicht schaden würde, wenn es Ding 5 GHz WLAN könnte, aber es ist halt so.
Das eigentlich Nbiße, was man hier sieht, ist.
Wollen wir mal ganz kurz gucken.
Hier guck mal.
finger ist erkennt man was da dran steht glaube nicht kennt man das da steht
zumindest ran l i minus i o n also sprich lithium ionen akkus kann man
direkt dran löten man kann die natürlich auch so an die pins anschließen aber
wenn man die hier dran anschließt dann ist eine lade elektronik dahinter das
heißt man kann mit dieser so hier oben kann man die dinger übrigens auch man
sieht ja hier oben kann man das auch anschließen wenn man eine batterie hat
mit dem passenden passende stecker als juli dankeschön für den sub ich hole mal
kurz eine batterie lasst uns mal kurz ausprobieren ob er dann ich habe vor
einer weile mal alles in solche kästchen sortiert das hat sich wirklich gelohnt
jetzt finde ich den kram auch zumindest das hier ist eine guck mal 2000 milli
ampere stunden batterie da sogar richtig was
drin und die kann man jetzt da oben anschließen ich hoffe das ist der gleiche
stecker ja ist es so und das coole ist dadurch dass es jetzt lade elektronik
drin hat kann ich jetzt per usb anschließen und das lädt moment das
probieren wir das probieren wir doch klappt mal aus holen wir mal im usb
wenn hier hinten ich war hier seht das nicht jetzt ist diese lidl steckdose der
hat ja der usb anschlüsse probieren wir mal aus ob das jetzt lädt wenn ich das hier so dran mache
ja ja guck dass das batterie charge symbol ist auf sieht man das dass er unten ist auf
rot da wo mein daumen ist das batterie charge symbol also sprich du kannst damit sogar die
batterie aufladen da ist lade elektronik drin und dementsprechend kannst du auch falls man
ein projekt plant mit solarpanels kann man sogar hier den output dran anschließen und
über die lade elektronik die batterie laden also muss ich echt mal sagen hut ab vor
dienst hier df robot die haben sich wirklich gedanken gemacht bei dem board
was ich damit vor habe ich will ein temperatursensor anschließen der meine
temperatur im fischteich misst damit mich home assistant alarmieren kann wenn
der droht zuzufrieren und das ist halt mitten im garten da ist kein anschluss
das heißt es muss schon so ein zwei jahre mal an der batterie überleben ja und das
verbringt den größten teil des tages im deep sleep und wacht alle drei vier stunden mal
auf schickt den neuesten status per sigbi und dann wieder ist gut zeigt er den akkustand auch
an da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher aber aber ich glaube man kann entweder über die referenz
spannung von irgendeinem pin muss man gucken was da eingebaut ist ungefähr sich ableiten
wieviel
ladestand die batterie noch hat vielleicht gibt es auch direkt die möglichkeit das auszulesen da
müssen wir mal schauen erinnert mich mal dran ich schreibe mir das mal auf hier also über
übertrieben geht es bestimmt also was was ja bei den alten schon ging ist was was ja bei den alten
boards schon gingen die sowas gar nicht dabei haben ist du konntest dir ein also konnte es
den kabel legen von deiner
용 richter so fre Hauseала
a
haben
naja
sendung
eingangspannung aufennan log
digitalkonverter
ich bin auch bin
und dann konntest du auslesen wie hoch die spannung ist
und die daran ungefähr ableiten wie voll die batterie ist weil die job mehr die haben ja glaube ich standopes hat man irmt was glaube ich wenn dierian
freiseitalon
buch hat mail
hat mail
czas
よね
heister
we love it
sie irgendwie so um die 4,2 glaube ich und wenn sie und wenn sie leer sind so um die 3,1 wenn
sie fast leer sind also man kann sich ungefähr anhand der batteriespannung ableiten so so prima
daumen habe ich noch im hinterkopf wie voll die batterie ist ich haue wasser weg wenigstens auch
warm gewesen letzten tag zumindest langer rede kurzer sinn ich mach das mal raus wir löten jetzt
das zeug an das war ja eigentlich nur probiere gerade batterie mal wieder ab aber mal weg
so also dran kommt wie gesagt ein ds 18 b 20 temperatursensor das sind die 08 fünfzigsten
temperatursensoren die man sich so vorstellen kann die gibt es im 10er pack für apple und ein
ei kann man kurz gucken die dinger kosten gucken wir mal die teuerste seite etwa für elektronik
sachen ds8 amazon ist der kram schon echt teuer ja guck mal hier kriegst du zehn stück oder wie
viel sind das
fünf stück 60 das ist teuer es fakt ich hoffe das sind wenigstens die mit fünf meter ok mit
fünf meter kabel kann man sich das vielleicht noch gefallen lassen aber die gibt es teilweise
noch günstiger ja das sind die eigentlichen sensoren wobei ich die wasserdichte verpackung
schon als finde ja also die kriegt man hinterher geschmissen und wenn man die noch zu größeren
stückzeilen im elektronikladen kauft kosten die nicht viel das sind so die quasi die die standard
standard temperatursensoren überhaupt die hat jeder schon mal der irgendwas in der richtung
gebastelt hat glaube ich verwendet oder sieht es bei euch aus habt ihr auch schon mal so einen
probiert also nicht nicht rein gebissen sondern probiert damit was zu bauen weil selbst wenn man
da mal einen kaputt macht ist nicht schlimm kein großer verlust haben so dann dann wird
man das noch mal schnell dran wird champ noch ist er nicht an sehr ist ja okay schauen wir mal
wie machen wir das jetzt am besten hier ich würde sagen als erstes machen wir mal ein bisschen als
erstes entwirre ich war mein lötkolben ich würde sagen als erstes machen wir hier mal ein bisschen
was nehmen wir denn für für gps also guckt mal hier haben wir ground und 3,3 volt oben also würde
ich sagen wir müssen uns mal die standard die die pin belegung angucken vorher bevor wir da was dran
nicht dass ich irgendwelche pins benutze die standardmäßig schon für was anderes benutzt
sind und ich die dann irgendwie um konfigurieren muss oder so sp 32 c6 pin out eine tabelle ist mir
lieber sowas geht auch also tabelle tabelle wäre eigentlich ganz nice gibt es nicht gibt es
normalerweise gibt es ja doch immer fertige tabellen für data sheet das hat immer klar oder gut gucken
hier also das sieht man nichts auf einem newtab ja also wie sie mit tiper 10 710 10 sieht unbenutzt
aus aber dann sonst noch tpi kekote wir nehmen gps 18 wir nehmen 18 also also der hier weil ach moment wo sind die Homebrewing
tipps
der hier weil ach nee moment wo sind die Homebrewing
Wo sind meine Dinger? Der nächste GPIO ist 18. Ja, der liegt da eigentlich ganz gut.
Migdial, danke schön für den Sub. 18 und 19 ist eigentlich wurscht.
Aber ich suche eben, normalerweise haben die doch so schöne Outputs, für was?
Ja, das ist die Espressif-Benahmung. Das blicke ich nicht durch, Alter.
Guck mal, ob die... Ich battle. Ob das Board von mir direkt sowas hat?
Ich feiere...
Beetle C2, ja?
Nee. Das da? Pinout?
Ey, scheiß drauf, ich nehme jetzt GPIO 18.
Ich habe keinen Bock, da eben nicht zu gucken.
Moin, Terrorkeks.
So, dann machen wir das doch mal schnell dran.
Also, mach ich das jetzt im Stehen oder im Sitzen? Weiß nicht genau.
So, machen wir diese komischen Dinger hier unten ab.
Also, was haben wir denn da?
Ich hoffe mal, die Farben von dem Zeug hier stimmt.
Also, das hier, ich gucke jetzt mal gar nicht nach.
Den roten machen wir an 3,3 Volt dran.
Den schwarzen machen wir an Ground dran.
Und den gelben machen wir an GPIO 18.
Und dann wird das schon funktionieren.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal ein bisschen Lötzinn an die...
Hier, das ist ein Dester.
Habe ich irgendwie mal hier den...
Nee, ich habe nur den Kombizangen-Champ.
Ja, okay.
Stand was über.
So, ich mache mal die Lötstation an.
Jetzt muss ich den Lötkolben hier reinstecken.
Okay.
Okay, ein Problem, was ich hier immer im Stream habe, wenn wir sowas machen, ist...
Euch fällt das nicht so auf, aber ich sehe immer nichts, weil hier oben ist das Ring-Light drumherum.
Ich kann also nicht nah dran gehen und von oben drauf gucken, was man normalerweise braucht.
Ich sitze quasi hier auf der Seite davor und kann nur so schräg...
Also, es ist ein bisschen kacke alles, ja.
Und wenn ich es zu nah an mir dran habe, dann...
Ja, äh...
Dann seht ihr nichts.
Ja, ihr seht ja jetzt auch nur...
Ganz knapp was.
Ich setze mich mal hin.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, das funzt jetzt halbwegs.
So.
Also, machen wir mal ein bisschen.
Machen wir ein bisschen Lötzchen hier an die Dinger dran.
Sieht man was?
Ja, ich glaube schon, ne?
So, haben wir ein bisschen Lötzchen an das Kabel dran gemacht.
Jetzt machen wir noch ein bisschen Lötzchen an die GPIOs dran, sodass es dann relativ easy aneinander pappt.
Lötz...
Ich muss danach das Fenster aufmachen, ja.
Ehemaliger Kollege auf der Arbeit hat gemeint, er riecht...
Ich rieche das gerne.
Ich finde...
Ich rieche das nicht gerne.
Es gibt aber auch Schlimmeres.
So, wo machen wir das jetzt dran?
Hier, guck.
An den GPIO kommt 3,3 Volt dran.
Man sieht nicht wirklich was.
Ich versuche es mal ein bisschen besser.
Hier kommt 3 Volt dran.
Hier direkt Ground.
Ja, dann...
Da sehe ich nichts.
Ich probiere es...
Ich probiere es mal so.
Ob ich es irgendwie...
Funzt.
Ja.
Mal abtupfen.
Also, ich habe jetzt erst einmal...
Ja, an die jeweiligen GPIOs.
Man sieht es hier ja.
Wenn das iPhone hat keinen Bock sich scharf zu stellen.
So ein Klecks drauf gemacht.
Und da können wir jetzt das Kabel dran machen.
Wie wäre ein Spiegel dann die Kamera anders ausgerichtet?
Tja, man kann das bestimmt super sophisticated machen, das Setup.
Aber ich brauche das so selten.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir fangen an...
Mit...
Mit 3,3 Volt.
Weil das ist hier unten außen.
Ich habe hier eigentlich auch so ein Teil, wo man das reinklemmen kann.
Wartet mal, das probieren wir aus.
Hatte ich lange keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Moment.
Mal gucken, ob das besser funzt damit.
Mega staubig.
Weil so lange nicht verwendet.
Ich mache es mal kurz sauber.
Guck mal, ich habe hier so ein Ding.
Bin ich mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Guck mal, da kann man...
So was hier.
Kann man sich drauflegen.
Und dann hat man so ein Halterungsteil.
Das ist der richtig High-IQ-Move jetzt.
Da kann man das so rein dingsen.
Hier, guckt.
Und dann kann man das so...
Ha!
Alter, das ist...
Das ist ja richtig Bro das Teil.
Weiß gar nicht, warum ich das nicht öfters benutze.
Guck mal hier.
Und da sind noch...
Wenn einem das nicht reicht, sind da sogar noch so extra...
Extra lange dran.
Doch weil das jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen...
Wups.
Ein bisschen viel des Guten ist.
Wobei ich jetzt deutlich besser was sehe.
Aber ihr nicht, ja?
Ihr seht jetzt nichts mehr.
Nee, das ist unscharf jetzt.
Wir nehmen das Kleine.
So, ist eigentlich nice.
Jetzt kann man hier richtig...
Richtig gut drauf gucken.
Ja.
Exzellent.
Jetzt seht...
Jetzt seht hoffentlich ihr was ganz gut.
Und ich auch.
okay so also was habe ich gesagt fangen wir an fang an mit 3 bis sie so fangen an mit 3,3 volt
als nächstes das ist richtig angenehm mit dem teil hier das sollte ich mal öfters verwenden
dann ground ja dran und jetzt was habe ich gesagt gpio 18 ja easy das sollte ich immer
nehmen das teil anstatt damit der hand rum zu fuddeln fertig richtig big pogg soll man
gerade noch mal anschauen ob das auch okay ist das ist richtig gut geworden und vor allem so
dass man es auch wieder abkriegt okay
gut dann hätten wir das auch dann können wir jetzt wieder umschalten jetzt müssen wir mal
gucken wie man diesen sensor ausliest ich schließe das board jetzt mal an usb c da
müsste noch die firmware vom letzten mal drauf sein ich löschte es jetzt noch mal weil ich
habe auf stream das noch ein bisschen hübscher gemacht so dass man das auch halbwegs versteht
was passiert okay
ich reise mal den flash und dann kann man anfangen flash
also ich zeige euch mal wie die firma aktuell aussieht ist relativ überschaubar das ist alles
156 teilen und es passiert nicht viel also ich hoffe ich habe ordentlich habt es ordentlich
gebaut im prinzip habe ich das was wir das letzte mal im stream copy pasted haben noch mal so
nachgebaut dass man halbwegs versteht was passiert ja und mal sehen ob der kopf nicht mehr passt aber
ja das dann der kopf liegt da hängt ich halt jetzt auf der forwarder nochmal auf der front
Ja, also es gibt, die Partitionen müssen wir vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen ändern, also im Prinzip passiert folgendes, wenn der Controller bootet, ist hier der Einstieg, dann wird erstmal Arduino initialized, was wir jetzt bis auf ein paar Helperfunktionen noch gar nicht großartig verwenden, dann startet der Zigbee, dann loopt er hier unendlich, dann startet der Zigbee, wenn der Zigbee startet, sieht folgendermaßen aus,
Viertelwissen, Dankeschön für 7, Porgas 27, 27er Raid, Dankeschön, ja, dann jumpt er hier rein, achso, und, na super, jetzt kann ich es euch gar nicht mehr zeigen,
wenn ich das Board schon ab habe, will das jetzt auch nicht, USB mäßig, äh, egal, können wir nachher gucken, Moin Patrick, wir haben gerade Temperatursensor dran gelöscht,
und gucken jetzt, wie man den anspricht, also, der steigt hier ein, dann startet der Zigbee, fragt mich bitte nicht, was dieser ganze Shit hier ist, das muss man laut dem Tutorial so machen, damit Zigbee funktioniert, also, so wie ich das verstehe, setzt man als erstes den Zigbee Controller, ja, für, für, für, was ist das, was ist Zigbee 2,4 Gigahertz auch, also man stellt hier irgendwie Spezialsachen ein, ja, für den, für den Zigbee,
Zigbee Controller, Radio Mode Native, Host Connection Mode None, whatever, das Tutorial sagt, das ist so, sollte es da irgendwelche Fehler bei geben, dann crasht, lasse ich den Controller crashen, achso, das ist übrigens was, was ich selbst gebaut habe, das ist standardmäßig nicht dabei, aber im Prinzip ist das einfach nur checken, ob der Return Wert okay ist, und wenn nicht, dann, äh, crashen, und neu starten, so,
dann, äh, kann man, äh,
kann man noch ein bisschen mehr Zigbee Config einstellen, man muss ihm sagen, dass man ein Device-Typ-ID ist, ach, End-Device ist das, wir sind ein Zigbee End-Device, hast du Empfehlungen für ein gutes Überwachungssystem für zu Hause, nicht wirklich, ich hab, ich hab ein paar, also, ich hab insgesamt sechs Kameras bei mir daheim, die, ich würde, ich würde die, ich würde aber nicht so weit gehen, die zu empfehlen, ich hab so eine Kombination aus, ja, Billing, Reolink, Reolink Kameras, oh, schon wieder andere Postleitzahl-Leak, okay, whatever,
Amazon, also, ich hab ein paar billige Reolink Kameras, wobei du da echt aufpassen musst, wenn du welche kaufst, dass du die kaufst, ohne Cloud-Zwang, die, die rein lokal funktionieren, ähm, weil ich glaub, das hier ist die, die nur mit, nur mit Cloud-Shit funktioniert, aber ich hab die, die ohne Cloud-Shit funktioniert, kann man hier WiFi-mäßig RTSP den Stream abgreifen, also, ich hab ein paar Reolink Kameras, noch ein paar alte Vice-Cams, und eine Raspberry Pi-Cam, also,
sprich, ich hab,
insgesamt,
lass mal überlegen, ich hab zwei,
ich hab zwei, äh, kleine
Vice,
Vice-Cam V1,
noch, die sind schon Jahre alt,
diese kleinen Fritz-Dinger hier,
zwei Stück,
eine hängt, äh,
überm Katzenklo, dass ich weiß, wann man sauber machen muss,
ist ja, äh,
eine hängt im Keller,
zum Auslesen vom Druck der Heizung,
dann hab ich noch eine
Vice-Cam V2,
äh,
die steht, äh, im Flur,
ne, äh,
Hahn,
heißen die, gell,
die steht im Flur,
die hab ich mir damals gekauft, weil's die super billig gab,
im Angebot, und man Custom-Firmware drauf flashen kann,
also, ich, ihr kennt mich ja, ich verwende nix mit, äh,
China-Firmware und, äh, China-Chinesen-App,
und Cloud-Only und sowas,
die kann man flashen, da gibt es hier
ein Repo auf GitHub,
das hier, das hab ich auf den Kameras installiert,
da kriegt man RTSP-Server drauf,
kann RTSP-Stream machen,
von den Kameras,
zumindest da hab ich insgesamt drei Stück von,
also zwei Vice-Cam V1, eine Vice-Cam Pan,
dann hab ich noch ne Raspberry Pi Kamera,
und,
zwei Reolink-Kameras,
eine für die Terrasse, und eine für den Hof,
ja, also im Prinzip ist bei mir verteilt
Eingangstür,
Hof, Terrasse,
Flur,
Katzenklo und Keller.
Die Raspberry Pi Kamera
ist nice,
eine blöde Sache an der Raspberry Pi Kamera ist,
ich hab noch kein gescheites Setup gefunden
für Infrarot-LEDs,
dass man ein bisschen hell machen kann.
Aber das brauch ich dafür auch nicht.
Meine Raspberry Pi Kamera, wisst ihr,
also man muss ja sagen, die Dinger
sind wirklich, ey, aber Ring,
ne, Ring kommt mir nicht ins Haus,
das braucht doch auch irgendwelche komische Cloud
und, äh, App-Geschichten,
da hab ich, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also die Raspberry Pi Kamera,
die ist wirklich enorm widerstandsfähig.
Das hätte ich selbst nicht gedacht.
Ich hab ne Raspberry Pi Kamera am Raspberry Pi,
ähm, nicht Pico,
wie heißt das andere Ding? Zero.
Also das vollwertige, vollwertige
Linux-Kiste drauf, das ist Zero.
Das ist noch ein Zero 1, WLAN,
WiFi, also,
Pi Zero W, der erste Pi Zero W
ist das. Da ist die Kamera.
Das Ding ist wirklich
mega schwachbrüstig,
das hat kaum was an, an, äh,
Raw Power.
Zumindest hab ich die
in den Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt,
den Raspberry Pi, mit der Kamera.
Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt,
ein Loch reingemacht in den Schrumpfschlauch,
dort wo die Kamera sitzt,
äh,
festgemacht mit Heißkleber
und seitdem
liegt diese Kamera
an meiner
Garage
bei Wind und Wetter
auf dem Garagendach
und
geht einfach.
Also, die ist per USB angeschlossen
innen drinne, ja,
Stecker. Die geht einfach.
Also ich mein, die ist wasserdicht
in diesem Schrumpfschlauch drinne, ja,
aber das Ding ist
seit Jahren
im Freien, in nem schwarzen
Schrumpfschlauch, also sprich,
das Ding wird im Sommer, wenn da die Sonne drauf
scheint, keine Ahnung, 80 Grad
heiß oder so, und im Winter,
wenn's richtig kalt ist, minus
10 Grad, das juckt den es nicht, geht einfach.
Es geht einfach, es hat
überhaupt keine Probleme, es läuft einfach.
Ja, richtig, richtig Panzermäßig.
Also das ist wirklich sehr stabil,
ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es das macht, aber
es geht einfach. Aha.
Okay, Flash ist erased,
jetzt können wir die Firma,
ich war ja grad dabei zu erzählen,
was das, was das Teil macht.
Ja, man muss setzen, dass man ein ZigBee Endgerät ist,
dann muss man irgendwelche Aging
Timeouts setzen, Leute, ich hab absolut keinen
blassen Schimmer, was das alles ist, das hab ich direkt
straight aus dem Tutorial.
Dann mach ich
Create ZigBee Sensor, da stell ich die ganzen
Infos ein, dass ich eigentlich ein
Temperatursensor über ZigBee
exportieren will, das funktioniert dann hiermit.
Muss dem erstmal
sagen, Mindestwerte des
Temperatursensors, Maximalwerte des
Temperatursensors, also vielleicht sollte ich
vielleicht Mindestwerte,
ja, sollte ich vielleicht Minus
20 oder so machen, anstatt
0.
Wobei 0 ist auch okay, dann muss ich das Ding
zu, dann muss ich das Ding halt zu machen.
Also Mindestwert,
Maximaltemperaturwert wird
eingestellt, dann auch Gram,
der straight aus dem Tutorial kommt.
Ich glaube, man sagt hier an der Stelle,
dass es ein
ZigBee Gerät ist, das ich als
Temperatursensor ausgeben soll,
wenn ich das soweit richtig verstehe.
Dann muss man dem Sensor noch eine
ID geben, ID 10
ist by the way ein Temperatursensor.
Warum? Man weiß es nicht,
das haben sich die ZigBee Leute ausgedacht, also
ID 10 gleich Temperatursensor.
Da muss man eben noch irgendwelche Profile
sagen, Sensor
Device ID
770, obviously.
Dann kann man noch einstellen,
wie das Ding heißt, von welchem Hersteller das
ist und weiterer Gram
direkt aus dem
Tutorial. Sollte das irgendwelche
Fehler geben, kackt es ab.
Und danach muss man noch einstellen,
irgendwie in welchem Intervall
ZigBee
Sachen reportet oder sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist auch direkt aus dem Tutorial.
Hier muss man nochmal die Sensor IP einstellen.
Minintervall,
Maxintervall, Delta,
U1600.
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist aus dem Tutorial.
So.
Das war es im Prinzip. Dann startet er hier
und
wenn er dann ZigBee bootet,
dann geht er hier rein.
Das war es übrigens dann auch schon mit der Firmware.
Ja, wenn er ZigBee bootet, dann geht er hier rein
und ruft
das mit verschiedenen Signalen auf, je nachdem
in welchem Zustand er gerade
bei ZigBee ist. Also entweder
wenn er das erste Mal startet, wenn er rebooted
wurde oder wenn er versucht
im ZigBee Netzwerk zu joinen.
Das können wir auch gleich ausprobieren, weil
ich habe hier eine Home Assistant Installation.
Ich muss mal kurz den ZigBee Stick
wieder reinstecken.
Ich habe hier eine Home Assistant
Installation.
Ist das der ZigBee Stick?
Ja.
Da ist ZigBee drauf. Da können wir auch gleich ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Also das letzte Mal im Stream hat das funktioniert.
Ohne Probleme nach dem
nach dem Tutorial.
Ich habe aber ja hier jetzt ein bisschen dran rum gebaut.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, ob es noch
funktioniert.
Ich würde sagen, wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Ok? Ok.
Also.
Ah ne, ich habe ja gerade den Flash
den Speicher gelöscht.
Ok, wir flashen diese Firmware jetzt mal
auf den... Moment.
Ich muss meinen...
Ich habe doch mir hier irgendwas kopiert.
Was benutzt du für eine VMS-Aufwand?
Kostet die was? Das ist vor allem eine Workstation.
Ja, die kostet was, aber die kriegst du bei
Keyshops schon sehr günstig.
So, ich flash
jetzt mal die Firmware drauf.
Ok, der startet.
Und...
Äh...
Irgendwas ist hier falsch an meiner Ausgabe,
oder? Da stimmt doch irgendwas.
Network Join
failed. Ja, das ist richtig. Ich habe ja noch
gar kein Zigbee-Network.
Ich glaube, mein Logging
ist etwas pepega.
Ich glaube, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt
gemacht.
Ich glaube, das ist ein reiner
Bug in meiner Darstellung.
Ja.
Network Join. Was habe ich denn hier komisches
programmiert?
Error? Weiß ich nicht.
Error to name.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
erwartet, dass das funktioniert.
Gut, ähm...
Hast du deinen Key aus dem Keyshop mal auf Google gesucht?
Ne, aber wer weiß.
Vielleicht haben die den einfach geklaut.
Also...
Hier habe ich irgendwas ernsthaft
verkackt bei dem Output.
Also Network Join failed, ist klar.
Das Ding versucht jetzt erstmal dem Zigbee-Network
beizutreten, was es nicht gibt.
Aber warum ist denn mein Output hier so kaputt?
Das muss ich gerade mal nachgucken.
Ich mache mal kurz den Status,
den Statuscode weg und flash nochmal neu.
Ich glaube,
ich habe irgendwas...
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas nicht richtig escaped
in meinem Output. Weil das mit dem
Logging habe ich vorhin erst noch eingebaut.
Ja.
Also, der hat ein Problem,
wenn der
den Error-Statuscode
rendert.
Wo ist das Problem?
Das Problem liegt irgendwo hier dran.
Das ist halt C++
und keine Ahnung, FNT,
Standard, Forward, Arcs...
Was auch immer.
Ich vermute, ich habe hier irgendwas
verkackt, ja.
nicht richtig escaped.
Könnte ich wetten, Leute. Irgendwas
ist hier falsch escaped drinne.
Irgendwas ist hier verkackt.
Aber ich weiß,
ich weiß nicht was.
Wie könnte man das jetzt ordentlich fixen?
Oder mal gucken, woran
es überhaupt liegt.
Wir machen jetzt mal hier...
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir schreiben anstatt hier mal
blub irgendwas und gucken, ob das
an den...
Meine, daran liegt es nicht.
It's is ja auf jeden Fall
vorne, da.
Das Problem.
Also es liegt hier irgendwie am Error.
Ich mach mal hier Cackle rein.
Gucken, ob das passt.
Ob das wirklich an der Formatierung
des Error-Outputs liegt.
Schauen wir mal.
Äh...
Fmt, Cackle...
Ja, ja, ja, okay.
Achso.
Also da geht es nicht kaputt.
Das muss an der...
Das muss an der Formatierung
des Error-Outputs liegen, wo ich irgendwas
kaputt gemacht habe.
Also irgendwo hier dran.
Wird Message vielleicht nicht richtig gesetzt?
Ist Message irgendwie kaputt?
Aha.
Nee.
Es liegt...
Oh, C++, Alter, Mann.
hier irgendwo dran.
Da ist...
Oh Mann, da ist irgendwo was nicht richtig escaped.
Guck mal,
ich hab 100 Pro hier irgendwas
reingeschrieben.
Boah, ich hab eigentlich gar keinen Bock,
das jetzt zu ver...
Zumindest liegt das nicht.
Da pointert irgendwas falsch
in C++.
Wir können es testweise
das hier nochmal rausschmeißen
und irgendwas reinschreiben.
Ob das dann immer noch kaputt ist?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es ein
Encoding-Problem ist.
Ich hab da vorhin noch
dran rumgebaut.
Das hab ich natürlich nicht ausprobiert, ob da alles funktioniert.
Das ist so easy, obviously
geht das alles dann.
Ey, da hat er keine Probleme.
Also es liegt auf jeden Fall irgendwie
am formatieren.
Wartet mal, wir testen jetzt
jetzt mal was.
Wir sagen hier printf
%s
und hauen hier einfach nur den Output raus,
ohne irgendwas anderes damit zu machen.
Gucken, ob der jetzt auch kaputt ist.
Na, Reboot wird uns da nicht
viel helfen, Leute.
Ey, jetzt kommt gar kein Output?
Ah, nee. Okay.
Hä?
Okay, whatever. Alter.
Ey, ich hab echt
kein... Ist printf
irgendwie im Arsch oder so?
Wir machen mal was. Wir machen ESP
Log
Warning. Wir tun einfach mal
so. Und dann %s
Output.
Mal da drüber.
Ob das geht? Oh, was ist jetzt
kaputt? Achso, Tag.
Eigentlich habe ich jetzt gar keinen
Bock, das zu debuggen. Und?
Und?
Äh?
Ja, wo kommt es denn her?
Was ist... Was ist
hier... Was ist hier dran
verkehrt?
String formatted? Vielleicht...
String formatted? Da ist ja nichts drin.
Und danach die Arguments.
Leute, ich habe absolut keinen
blassen Schimmer, was da...
Was da ein Problem gerade ist.
Also für mich sieht es so aus, als greift das auf irgendwie
Speicher zu, wo es nicht zugreifen soll. Aber warum?
Wir haben keine Argumente hier hinten dran.
Daher kann es
nicht kommen. Das sollte eigentlich nur dieser
Format-String sein. Und sonst...
Sonst nichts.
Machen wir mal args weg. Das brauchen wir an der
Stelle ja gar nicht.
Da hält man sich wieder mit dem übelsten Bullshit auf.
Und jetzt?
Hä? Irgendwas hat er
mit meinem Format-String.
Mag er nicht.
Da sollte eigentlich
Sigbee Network Join Failed drinnen stehen.
Aber er schreibt...
Okay.
Was hat der für Probleme mit diesem Format-String?
Bitteschön.
Was geht denn da gerade kaputt?
Ich sehe nichts, was überhaupt kaputt
gehen könnte, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist richtig.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Okay, wenn man da jetzt... Was hatte ich da vorhin drin?
Sigbee Network Join Failed. Okay.
Sigbee Network
Join Failed.
Ist da aus versehen vielleicht
irgendwelche
Sonderzeichen rein
fabriziert,
die ich da gar nicht haben will oder so?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist das denn?
Und wenn ich da nur
Network Join Failed reinschreibe?
Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder, Mann?
Hä?
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was
da...
Wahrscheinlich ist das eindeutig Skill-ish hier.
Mach mal Underscores
anstelle von Spaces.
Ich glaube, der ist abgekackt.
Ich muss mal kurz Reset-Knopf drücken.
Ist manchmal...
Wo kann denn jetzt hier bitteschön noch ein
großartiges Problem sein?
Soll ich mal hier... Moment.
Darf man hier in Format rein?
Oder muss das hier auch ein C
String sein?
Dass es da nicht mal buggt? Keine Ahnung.
Ich probiere einfach sinnlos rum.
Aber man würde eigentlich vermuten,
dass man Format in Format
schachteln darf.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Also es scheint ja eindeutig
hier dran zu liegen.
An dem ersten
Format.
Weil wenn ich das weg mache, ist alles gut.
Blub.
Es scheint ja wirklich
da dran zu liegen.
Und nicht an dem Output.
Also geben wir jetzt mal nur Blub aus.
Ach, was ist denn jetzt?
Äh...
Naja, okay.
Können wir eigentlich weg machen.
Das ist wieder
irgendein C++ Shit.
Wenn man am Ende,
wenn man drauf gekommen ist, dann sagt man
Ach ja, logisch.
Hä, das funktioniert?
Also liegt es
an dem...
Also liegt es an dem Zusammenfügen
von...
Aber was ist daran
jetzt kaputt?
Die erste Ausgabe funktioniert ja auch.
Offensichtlich.
Leute.
Ich bin mit meinem C++
Latein am Ende.
Also der erste
String vollkommen okay.
Den zweiten mag er nicht.
Also der hier ist gut.
Aber sobald
ich Blub und Kackel zusammenfüge,
ist es ein Problem.
Und warum ist das so?
Man weiß es nicht.
Fragt ChatGPT.
Ich bin grad nicht eingeloggt.
Also ich hab ernsthaft
überhaupt keine Ahnung, was dem
sein Problem gerade ist.
Liegt es am C-String?
Ne, kannst du auch weglassen.
Format checkt, Format in Format.
Oder auch...
Moment.
Achso, ja gut.
Muss man, dass dieses...
Dass das
gebrinnt Zeug das checkt.
Liegt es am Compile Flag?
Jetzt weiß ich.
Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass das eigentlich bis jetzt funktioniert.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum der jetzt
auf einmal Schmerzen damit hat.
Eigentlich will ich
das gar nicht machen jetzt.
Join failed.
Okay,
ich mach das jetzt nochmal neu.
Ja.
Ich mach das jetzt nochmal neu.
Wir haben noch ein Format String.
Wo ich hier F einsetze.
So weit, so gut.
Da sollte jetzt eigentlich noch nichts passieren.
Was?
Ich kann Format String nicht in Format String einsetzen.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Ne, habe ich nicht mehr.
Habe ich nicht mehr.
Hat der
irgendwie Probleme?
Mit so nested Formats
oder so?
Aber dann sollte der Krempel gar nicht kompilieren.
Ach nee, ist nicht Standard.
Das ist FMT.
Mittlerweile ist es Standard.
Aber bei ESP32 Sachen nicht.
Ich check es echt nicht.
Ich mein, es scheint nichts
Schlimmes zu sein.
Es crasht nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt mal was anderes.
Jetzt mal ganz blöd.
Hier wird er jetzt meckern, dass
ich eine Expression habe,
die not found.
Okay.
Jetzt ist ja kaum noch
ein Unterschied zu da unten.
Und wenn es jetzt geht, verstehe ich es nicht.
Hä?
Und was ist da jetzt?
Großer Unterschied?
Ah ja, gut.
Dann nennen wir das Output.
Meistens weg.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt
broken ist.
Äh, what?
Ah, Moment. Der ist...
Äh...
Kannst du mal die reine ASCII-Zeichen aus...
Alter, Mann! C++!
Was ist das Problem jetzt schon wieder?
Expected Primary Expression.
What? Was? Was willst du von mir?
Ah, guck mal, da ist ein
Semikolon drin.
Okay, ja, das hätte man sehen...
Skillissue, Skillissue.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob jetzt die Ausgabe
funktioniert.
Jetzt die Ausgabe, okay.
Okay, und was genau
ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dem
und dem, was vorhin nicht ging?
Naja, irgendwas mit
Standard, Forward, Arcs und so, aber...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Soll mir recht sein?
Äh, das bleibt jetzt so.
Das bleibt jetzt so. Solange es funktioniert, ist
okay, ja. Da fehlt
jetzt zwar ein bisschen was, aber für heute
soll's das tun, ja.
Weil eigentlich will ich Temperatursensor
auslesen und mich nicht mit irgendwelchen komischen
String-Ausgaben und C++-Shit
beschäftigen. So.
Joining ZigBee Network.
Join failed. Okay. Darf ich denn
jetzt auch, ohne dass er
wieder abkankt, ZigBee Network
Join failed schreiben?
Gut.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es funktioniert.
Wir gehen jetzt mal in Home Assistant und
130, okay.
Zeitpunkt 130.
Und melden da mal unser ZigBee-Gerät an.
Wir müssen aber vorher noch...
Ja, der Network-Key
ist falsch. Ja, den kannst du ruhig anzeigen.
Ich brauch den eh net.
Ich will...
Ich hab meine Integrations...
Ich will, dass wir neu
anfangen mit ZigBee Integrations.
Delete. Yes.
So.
ZigBee...
ZigBee... Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
ZigBee Home About? Ja.
Ich mach jetzt mal einen ZigBee-Stick.
Der fragt
einen jetzt, ob man wieder von vorne anfangen will oder
nicht. Will ich. Ich will einen neuen Key generieren
und alles. Zumindest
bilde ich mir ein, dass er einen das fragt.
Ja.
Erase Network Settings and
create a new network. Jawoll.
Und danach testen wir mit dem ZigBee
2MQTT, weil eigentlich bin ich scharf
darauf, dass es damit funktioniert.
Ob die Home Assistant-ZigBee-Sache funktioniert, ist mir
relativ egal.
Home Assistant macht Badge.
Kann mir jemand erklären, warum das so lahm ist?
Erschrecklich.
So.
Äh...
Moment, hat der mein...
Was ist das?
Ah! Das ist die...
Das ist die Lidl-Steckdose, oder?
Guck mal, der hat mein Gerät
schon direkt gefunden.
Temperature unavailable. Ja, ich hab
ja auch noch nichts gesendet. Guck mal, der hat mein
ZigBee-Gerät gleich schon gefunden hier.
Ne, hat er nicht. Hä?
Ist das noch das alte vom letzten Mal
auf dem Stick drauf?
Ich bin etwas verwirrt gerade.
Hätte der nicht einfach... Hätte der das
nicht eigentlich vergessen sollen, was da drauf...
Okay. Add device.
Ja.
Network joint. Blablabla. Channel hier irgendwas.
Okay.
Ne, guck, da ist es.
Da ist es. Zack. Ja.
Also,
das hier scheint mir die Steckdose zu sein.
Ach! Jetzt weiß ich, warum
er das zugeordnet hat. Weil wir das letzte
Mal das schon mit Home Assistant gepairt haben.
Das hat überhaupt nichts mit dem Stick zu tun.
Das sind einfach noch alte Geräte. Die können wir jetzt...
Die können wir jetzt hier rausschmeißen, im Prinzip. So.
Das ist der alte. Den...
Wie löscht man den Shit jetzt?
Remove. Und...
Die Lidl Steckdosenleiste.
Remove.
Ja.
So, passt. Wir haben aktuell minus
327 Grad. Easy.
Also, das Pairen hat funktioniert mit dem Gerät.
Also, ihr seht hier, da hat
sich... hat sich verbunden mit meinem
Home Assistant ZigBee Network.
Jetzt checken wir mal, ob wenn ich reboote,
ob er sich wieder reconnectet.
In den ZigBee.
Joining ZigBee Network.
Ich glaube, der ist gejoined.
Der ist... Ich bin bloß zu... Ich hab bloß keinen
Ausgabe gemacht. Kann das sein?
Mir fehlt noch eine Ausgabe.
Guck mal, der sagt hier, Status ist okay.
Aber ich glaube, hier
haben wir noch eine Ausgabe.
Weil es ist Factory New,
ist es nicht. Es hat auch keinen Error.
Hier fehlt einfach noch eine Ausgabe. Jetzt können wir vielleicht
eine extra Funktion auslagern.
Lass mal kurz flashen. Das ist ein
ESP32C6.
In den ZigBee... ZigBee... Ja.
Okay. Funktioniert. Also.
Der ZigBee Part funktioniert.
Ich übertrage noch per ZigBee keinerlei
Daten. Das haben wir aber das letzte Mal testweise schon
gemacht. Das funktioniert.
Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht wieder Fake
Daten übertragen, sondern ich will jetzt meinen
Temperatursensor auslesen. Aber vorher,
Leute...
So.
Da bin ich wieder. Was kann man da sonst noch einblenden
lassen?
RSSI.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so übel. Das können wir tatsächlich
einblenden.
Wie auch immer man das aktiv...
Das ist nämlich die
Empfangsstärke. Warum eigentlich den Weg
über ZigBee zu MQTT und nicht direkt
MQTT? Äh...
Weil...
ZigBee irgendwie in MQTT
reinkommen muss. Außerdem geht's noch
nicht mal über MQTT aktuell.
Es geht über die Native
Home Assistant Integration.
Es ist nur ZigBee ohne MQTT.
Was ich mit
Home Assistant steuer? Boah...
Sehr vieles
steuer ich mit Home Assistant.
Ich hab ne Anzeige, was
in meinem Elektroauto
abgeht.
Die Wetterstation,
wann der Müll rausgebracht werden muss,
der Wasserdruck in der Heizung,
generell die Heizung,
dann ob es irgendwo Überschwemmungen
im Keller gibt,
Licht teilweise
im Wohnzimmer,
das Shield TV, die Heizungsthermostate,
mehrere
Steckdosen, LED
Leisten.
Heizlüfter im Bad.
Ganz wichtig. Ein paar Fenster
kann ich steuern da drüber.
Ich klick hier grad mal durch,
weil so viel Zeug ist, dass ich mir die Hälfte nicht merken kann.
Sogar mein Weihnachtsbaum.
Steckdose im Stall.
Ja, und das wird
jetzt für den Fischteich. Hier.
Fischteich.
Aha, RSSI is unknown.
Sadge.
Dann wird's wieder disabled.
Okay, also, ZigBee
Kunst.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen, wie wir den Temperatursensor auslesen.
Also, ESP
EDF, DS. Gucken wir mal, ob's da schon
fertige Libraries oder sowas für gibt.
Example
Driver. Aha.
Okay.
ESP 32 kompatibel
Example for integrated
Okay.
ESP
OWB.
Es gibt doch bestimmt
irgendwelche offiziellen Libraries
für so ein verbreitetes Ding.
Okay.
Ich hab ne Idee. Wir suchen mal in der ESP
Registry.
Warum hast du einen Heizlüfter im Bad?
Weil's mir manchmal
zu kalt ist und ich schnell
warm haben will.
DS 18
Wie hieß das Ding? DS.
Doch, doch, da ist
eine Heizung drin.
ESP kann doch per WLAN MQTT.
Ja, aber nicht aus dem Garten raus.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich's über SIGBEE
machen will. Das kommt in Fischteich
im Garten. Das muss erstens
mit Batterie laufen. WLAN und Batterie
verträgt sich meistens nicht so gut.
Und es braucht ne
größere Reichweite.
Ich habe im Garten keinen WLAN Empfang.
Aber ich hab ein paar
SIGBEE Steckdosen in den Stellen.
Das heißt, da wird das Signal weitergeleitet.
SIGBEE ist da
wie gemacht für. Was haben wir denn hier?
DS 18 B20
Device Driver. Das ist
sieht doch gut aus. Das will ich haben.
Add Dependency
DS 18 B20
Du hast Stelle, wann wo Bauernhof.
Da war früher, also
meine Uroma oder so, die haben da
noch Viecher drin gehabt.
Mittlerweile sind die
leer. Das sind drei Ställe sind das.
In dem einen ist
die olle Werkstatt vom
Opa drin, in die ich nicht reingehe, weil
das alles so dreckig ist.
Und die anderen sind mittlerweile
nur Abstellkram.
SIGBEE ist Mesh. Ja, SIGBEE ist
mehr Mesh als WLAN Mesh.
Kannst du ein kabelgebundenes
System aufbauen. Wie soll ich ein Kabel
im Garten zu meinem Fischteich legen?
Ohne den halben Hof aufzubuddeln.
Telefonmast.
Schnurrtelefon bauen.
Leute, wir machen
Laser. Laser
Kommunikation am besten.
SIGBEE ist da wie gemacht
für.
Also wie funsten das jetzt?
Vielleicht sollen wir erstmal bilden.
Einmal Buildchamp.
Ja, Compiler stellts.
Wie siehts aus?
Erstmal das halbe Internet kompilieren.
Ich mach einfach Leute, ich weiß,
ich mach ne LTE Karte rein.
Warum kompliziert, wenns auch einfach
geht?
Also wie funst das jetzt hier?
One Wire Bus
Kein Dark Fiber.
Du weißt warum es Dark Fiber heißt.
Ne?
Weil die Dinger schon liegen und unbenutzt sind.
Ich versuch da hier gerade halbwegs durch
zu blicken, wie das funst.
Also ich
lasst uns mal wieder
Copy-Pasten.
Wir machen mal hier sowas.
Void
Init Sensor
So.
Und da kommt jetzt rein.
One Bus Handle
GPIO
Okay, wir machen
Was hab ich gesagt? GPIO 18 haben wir dran
gelötet, gell?
GPIO Nummer
Das ist nicht included?
Okay, ja.
Dann includen wir das mal.
Include
Wie heißt denn der Kram?
Die eigentliche Library? DS irgendwas?
DS sowas hier?
Reicht das zum
includen? Ja.
Also Bus gleich 0.
Bus Config
One Wire Bus
Ich kopier das mal.
Ich weiß eh nicht, was das macht.
Ist undefined.
Warum ist das jetzt undefined?
Muss ich auch noch
Include
One Wire
Bus vielleicht?
Ja, nice.
So, dann
Error checken.
Moment, die haben mehrere Devices.
Ich Copy-Paste mir mal das gesamte Ding
und dann räume ich das gerade mal ein bisschen auf.
Zum Testen können wir uns diesen ganzen
Schmodder hier übrigens sparen.
Wir schmeißen das Delay raus
und wir schmeißen die ganze
ZigBee-Geschichte raus.
Wir wollen ja eigentlich nur
InitSensor
Wir wollen ja eigentlich nur mal gucken,
ob der Sensor funktioniert.
InitSensor, bla bla bla.
Warum Handle? Nein.
Wir haben einen, das reicht.
Wer braucht
Kommentare, wenn man das einfach
first try richtig macht?
Error check.
Creating, Starting,
Search.
Alles klar.
Logs kommen weg.
So, die Schleife brauchen
wir jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Weil wir nur noch
einen haben.
Search
Result, ESP ok. Ja, das ist in Ordnung.
Das ist auch gut.
New Device,
das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen im Prinzip nur noch das Handle
dafür.
So.
Logger.
Log.
Info.
Found.
Unknown.
So, da sieht es doch schon ein bisschen
simpler aus. Error check.
Ok.
Logger.
Pogu.
Ok, wenn Pogu im Chat
äh, im Chat
in der
Konsole steht, dann wissen wir, dass er irgendwas
gefunden hat.
Ok, wir haben das schon mal ohne Compile-Fehler hinbekommen.
Das ist enorm, Pog.
Weil es ist C++.
Pogu!
Er hat den
Temperatursensor gefunden.
Schließe ich da draus zumindest.
Er sagt Found
und Pogu. Was natürlich
obviously jedem sagen sollte und der
Temperatursensor wurde entdeckt.
Also, wenn das nicht die aussagekräftigste
Log-Meldung
aller Zeiten ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
So, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Triggering a temperature
conversion and then reading
the data.
Ok.
Dann readen wir mal die
Data.
Also, das hier brauchen wir schon wieder alles nicht.
Äh, das gibt es
auch nur einmal.
Das gibt es weiterhin auch nur einmal.
Äh, Temperature haben wir nicht angelegt.
Was muss denn das für ein Typ sein?
Ein Float. Float
Temp.
Ich mag Abkürzungen.
So.
Und dann Logger
Log
Info
Äh, ja.
Temp.
Ach ja. Und vorher müssen wir
das Ganze. Ich habe doch irgendwie so eine Convert
Function. Convert
Sensor. Ja, also ZigBee kann
mit Floats nichts anfangen. Deswegen
muss man
das Float mal 100
nehmen
und dann als in 16 casten.
Ist das jetzt
Temperature oder Temporary? Ja, das ist
Interpretationssache.
Das ist um das Skill Level des
Entwicklers zu raisen. Bisschen.
Du willst die Temperatur aus deinem Fischteich loggen.
Korrekt. Also wir sollten
hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20 Grad oder so
drin haben. 22,8
22,8
22,7
26,7
26,8
26,9
26,11
26,12
Onlyfans ist out.
Ich bin auf Fansly.
Okay, 2. Aha.
Also, Moment. Ich setze mich mal kurz drauf.
Also nur draufsetzen.
Jetzt kein...
Kein Zäpfchen oder so, ja?
Okay, ich sitze drauf.
Es geht hoch, Leute.
23,3.
23,6.
23,8.
24.
Guck mal.
Er checkt es, dass ich drauf sitze.
Die Frage ist...
Jetzt lassen die Leute alle wieder ihre Fantasien
im Chat aus, Alter.
Lass mal einen fahren, Mann.
Und jetzt, wenn ich das wieder raus...
Also...
Nicht, wenn ich es einfach
hier wieder raushole.
Ja, nicht rausziehe.
Nicht, dass man jetzt das Falsche denkt.
Dann mal gucken,
ob es wieder...
ob es wieder kälter wird.
Klemm mal unter Arm und guck,
ob es auf 36...
30 Grad kommt.
Gute Idee.
Die Frage ist noch, wie genau das Ding ist.
Die Dinger sind recht gut.
Sie wird damit jetzt nichts
Wissenschaftliches durchführen oder so.
Okay, wir sind jetzt bei drei...
Es steigt immer noch weiter.
Leute, ich muss hier nebenbei mal was futtern, ja?
Sonst ist es nämlich durchgeweicht.
Das ist übelst gesundes Zeug,
was ich hier zum Essen habe.
Das hätte ich selbst vor ein paar Jahren
noch nicht gedacht, dass ich sowas esse.
Das ist Haferflocken.
So, Quark mit Haferflocken und...
Äh, wie heißt das?
Blaubeeren.
Sonst weicht das nämlich zu sehr durch.
Okay, Leute.
Ich steck's mir mal unter den Arm.
Und wir gucken,
so Fieberthermometer-mäßig,
ob das irgendwie 36 Grad wird gleich.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich drauf sitze,
ist es wahrscheinlich eh nicht so.
Jetzt kann ich meinen linken Arm nicht bewegen,
weil ich das da drunter stecken hab.
Das ist ziemlich suboptimal zum Essen.
Also das sollte jetzt bei...
Also maximal 37 Grad halt aufhören.
Ähm...
Ja, ich hab was zu XZ gesagt,
aber das ist schon ein paar Tage her.
Seitdem nicht mehr.
Also nix, was man sich im Wort angucken müsste.
Das sieht auch gut aus, oder?
Es wird eindeutig langsamer.
Mehr macht's gerade nicht.
Es nähert sich dem an.
Ich setz mich noch mal drauf.
Gucken, ob es da wärmer wird.
Ne.
Es wird kälter.
Mein...
Ah.
Liegt.
Mein Arsch ist kälter,
als mein Arm.
Mit Hose oder ohne.
Mit.
McFly, danke für den Sub.
Aber man sieht,
die Temperatur kommt auf jeden Fall schon ungefähr hin.
Okay.
Ich schmeiß das mal wieder auf die Erde.
Mal gucken.
Dann müssten wir wieder gleich so...
22 Grad oder sowas haben.
22,87.
Also man sieht,
der schnellste Sensor ist das jetzt nicht.
Aber das Material muss sich ja auch erstmal anpassen wieder und sowas.
Aber man sieht, die sind schon recht genau.
Dauerhafte Arschtemperatureinblendung.
Warum sollte das irgendjemand, der zuschaut im Stream, interessieren,
was mein Pobbes für eine Temperatur hat?
Wie weit geht der Sensor bis ins Minus?
Kann ich dir sagen.
Der kann...
Minus 1,5 Grad.
Minus 1,55 bis 125 Grad.
Also nix zum in den Backofen hängen.
0,5 Grad.
Plus minus 0,5 Grad Genauigkeit.
Zwischen minus 10 und plus 85.
Also die Dinger sind einfach billig und genau genug.
Und wasserdicht vor allem.
Was ist denn bitteschön der Parasitic Power Mode?
Holt er sich da seine Spannung aus dem GPIO Pin oder wie?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Du musst gar kein VCC anschließen.
So ist aber auf jeden Fall die schönere Variante.
Ich habe ja auch genug Pins.
Guck, das geht wieder runter.
Also das kommt schon gut hin.
Wir brauchen 1,5 Mikroampere zum Abfragen.
Das ist kein Ding, weil er fragt ja nur alle vier Stunden ab.
Also Leute, ich muss mal kurz fertig essen, sonst weicht das hier zu sehr durch.
Also ich...
Zwei Drittel sind schon weg.
Aber findet ihr nicht auch?
Das ist erstaunlich.
Easy war das jetzt auszulesen.
Ich meine, das hier ist alles, was man braucht.
Okay, die Komplexität steckt in der Library drin.
Aber whatever, interessiert mich ja nicht.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was das Ding hier so genau treibt, aber mein.
Warum auch?
Aber wir können das doch ein bisschen schöner machen.
Aber eine ordentliche Log Meldung.
Wie sagst du dem nun, dass er in Deep Sleep gehen soll?
Nach vier wieder?
Ja, das müsste es sein.
Dann müsstest du es hier unten machen.
Dann würdest du sagen, boah, habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht Deep Sleep.
Also hier machst du Deep Sleep Start und dann kannst du ihm vorher sagen, ESP Deep Sleep
Timer.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Müsste ich ins Tutorial gucken, wie das geht.
Im Prinzip sagst du dem hier, wann er wieder aufwachen soll und dann sagst du Deep Sleep
und dann sleept er.
Und dann wacht er auf und macht genau den gleichen Schritt wieder und geht wieder in
Deep Sleep.
Klingt sehr traurig.
Meint ihr, der ist sad, gell?
Der ESP?
Der ESP32?
Das wäre aber traurig, wenn der Sadge ist.
Ich will nicht, dass mein Microcontroller Sadge ist.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Gehen wir das mal ein bisschen um.
Next Device.
Machen wir auch dahin.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wenn wir das ein bisschen vereinfachen können.
Ich nenne den Kram auch mal um.
Next Device.
Ich mag die Schreibweise einfach besser.
Bus.
Config.
So.
Und jetzt machen wir.
Das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Das brauchen wir schon mal gar nicht mehr.
Das machen wir jetzt global.
Irgendwie keine Ahnung, äh.
Muss man das static machen?
Static Sensor Handle.
So.
Okay.
Und jetzt habe, ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen können.
Ich habe mir nämlich was gebaut für ESP Fehler Codes.
Und zwar, pass mal auf.
Fifad Mode kommt jetzt.
Exzellente Fifad Mode.
Guck mal, ich habe mich ein bisschen von.
Ähm.
Der C Sharp Standard Library inspirieren lassen.
inspirieren lassen. Ich habe hier eine Methode
gebaut. ESP Error
Any. Und dem kann man
Errors übergeben
und beim ersten
Error, der
wirklich eine Fehlermeldung ist,
geht er raus
und returned true.
Also könnte ich jetzt ja sagen,
also quasi sowas hier,
nur schöner.
Also könnte ich quasi sagen, ESP
Error Any.
Dann haue ich
den hier rein.
Das machen wir weg.
Dann haue ich den hier rein.
Machen wir hier New Lines rein.
Next Device.
Und da machen wir jetzt
ein If drumherum.
Und wenn das...
Geht's nicht?
Ah, man kann es nicht.
Ich muss hier...
Oh.
Das ist hässlich, oder?
Wir können es...
Leute, wir nutzen
C++ Magic.
Können wir das nicht konverten?
Automatisch in ein Bool?
Wie geht denn das?
C++
Implicit Convert Bool.
Wie macht man sowas denn?
Oh, ich muss
immer noch fertig essen.
So, hä?
What?
Wollst du es jetzt? Das geht?
Guck mal. Ey, das ist ja richtig
Pfeifert.
Jetzt kann ich da sogar ein If schreiben.
Das ist doch schöne Schreibweise hier.
Any ESP Error.
Dann Log.
Log Error.
No Sensor Found.
Und dann Reboot.
Weil dann kann ich eh nicht weitermachen.
Ich finde, das ist richtig gut lesbar, oder?
Besser als 5x
gerappt.
Check Error.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Config.
Wir können das sogar noch weitertreiben.
Wir können das hier nehmen.
Config.
Schreiben wir das mal aus.
Semikolon.
Und dann können wir sogar das hier noch reinpacken.
Next.
Device.
ES Config.
Sensorhandle.
Und jetzt können wir uns diesen ganzen
Shit
hier sparen.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen zu viel gelöscht.
Ich bin mir nicht
so ganz.
Sicher gerade noch besser.
Wir können das noch fertig machen.
Ja, wir schmeißen Scheiß, Scheiß auf Buhl Overload.
Wir können einfach sagen.
Weil wir wollen ja eh abbrechen.
Leute, wir wollen ja eh abbrechen.
Guck mal, wir können einfach sagen Logger.
Abbruch werden Error.
Das hier rein.
Plus die Default Fehlermeldung.
Easy.
Das gefällt mir jetzt.
Das ist auch, finde ich, ganz gut lesbar.
Ja, abkacken, wenn es irgendeinen Fehler hierbei gibt mit dieser Meldung.
So, das hier.
Ja, das können wir lassen, wobei da können wir das auch benutzen.
Hier mein selbst gebastelter Overload.
Logu Log Pogu.
Sensor Händel.
Wir schauen mal, ob das jetzt noch funktioniert nach meiner Bastelei hier.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Funktioniert das noch oder wird es nicht funktionieren?
Habe ich irgendwo einen Denkfehler drin?
Okay, wir.
Wir bilden erst mal.
Also, wir haben wieder 23,12, 23,18 Grad.
Geht.
First try.
Ich muss sagen.
Das ist echt.
Halbwegs lesbar.
Wir können noch sagen, hier unten.
Logger.
Loginfo.
Es gibt nämlich.
Wo war das?
Loginfo.
Oder auch die Adresse vom Sensor. Mal gucken, was er für eine Adresse überhaupt ausgibt.
Ja, foundsensor.at. Ah, natürlich, an der Adresse. Ja, logisch.
Hätte ich vorher gewusst. Hätten wir eigentlich gar nicht ausgeben müssen.
Aber es funktioniert.
Übrigens, ich finde meine Log-Ausgabe viel schöner in der Formatierung,
auch mit dem fetten Info und sowas, als die offizielle ESP-Log-Ausgabe.
Guck mal, ihr seht ja, ich habe sogar in meinem Log-Output
zu Debug-Zwecken die Datei und die Zeile, wo der Log-Output geschrieben wird.
Also sprich, wenn da jetzt als Output kommt, Error, könnte ich sogar nachgucken,
welche Zeile das ist.
Ja, das war's. Also nicht für heute, aber für das Auslesen vom Sensor.
Jetzt müssen wir den Kram hier bloß noch verpacken in einen eigenen Thread
oder in eine eigene Schleife.
Die wir dann per ZigBee an Home Assistant schicken.
Also, starten wir ZigBee.
Nach Init-Sensor kriegt er mal 500 Millisekunden Zeit.
Wobei, das Ding läuft später an der Batterie.
Der kriegt 100 Millisekunden Zeit, sich zu akklimatisieren.
Die neue Home Assistant-Updates.
Ja, ich lese immer den Blog.
So, jetzt starten wir noch einen neuen Tag.
Ach, übrigens, wisst ihr, was mein Logger auch macht?
Mein Logger ist richtig pfeifett.
Der loggt den Namen vom Task mit.
So, jetzt machen wir sowas wie ZigBee.
Nennen wir das Ganze mal Sensor.
Start, Start, Start, Start-Sensor ist doof.
Start-Read-Sensor vielleicht, sowas.
So, Start-Read-Sensor.
Okay, und der soll jetzt im Hintergrund Temperatur auslesen.
Per ZigBee, per ZigBee schicken.
Also, nachdem es ja ein eigener Task ist, while true.
Und da kommt ein Delay von einer Sekunde rein.
Und da kommt von 5 Sekunden jetzt zum Ausprobieren.
Oder interessiert dich was Konkretes, was ich irgendwie zu irgendeinem Update sage?
Also, ich freue mich jeden Monat, die Home Assistant-Updates zu lesen.
In letzter Zeit hat sich ein bisschen viel Kosmetik getan.
Aber Kosmetik?
Das darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Ist das, was Noobs zu solchen Produkten bringt?
Ja, die Voice-Geschichte ging ein bisschen an mir vorbei.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Okay, also.
Wir packen das wieder.
Ich finde die Funktion mega praktisch, die ich da gebaut habe.
ESP-Error.
Any.
Erst das da.
An das da.
Okay, muss man wirklich.
Dann Error.
Dann sagen wir sowas wie.
Beste Zeit.
Das war schon ewig her.
Dann werfen wir ein Warning an der Stelle, wenn es einen Fehler gegeben hat.
Und sagen, irgendwie Read Temp Failed.
Das kann weg.
Das Info unten ist okay.
Das können wir da lassen.
Schreiben wir einfach wie Temp Read.
Grad Celsius.
Ich hoffe, das Ding.
Moment, liest das?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Kekona Alarm.
Liest das überhaupt in Z...
Ja, macht es.
Noch mal Glück gehabt, Alter.
Nicht in Ounces und Fahrenheit und solche komischen Dinger.
Man weiß nie.
Kekona Time.
Wo ist denn mein Kekona Emote, wenn man das braucht?
Ich habe das Kekomrit Emote.
Hier.
Aber es ist, es ist Celsius.
Zum Glück.
Besser?
Viele das Grad Celsius in ASCII-Code ausgeben.
Was?
Nochmal auf Deutsch, please.
Jetzt haben wir das ausgelesen.
Warte, komm her.
Sekunde.
Jetzt müssen sie es per ZigBee schicken.
Das habe ich vergessen, wie das funktioniert.
Das hatten wir das letzte Mal.
Haben wir das schon gemacht.
Aber keine Ahnung mehr.
Da muss ich mal nachgucken hier.
Irgendwo.
Hier ist es doch noch.
ZigBee Sensor.
Ne.
Was?
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Ja.
Wie ging das nochmal mit dem ZigBee?
Irgendwas mit LOG.
Ah ja, hier.
Hier.
Temperature.
LOG Acquire.
Endpoint bla.
Okay, das, das hier.
Das brauchen wir.
Um das per ZigBee zu senden.
Also.
Measured Value Convert.
Ja, da habe ich was eigenes für Convert.
Und außerdem heißt es Temp und nicht Temperature.
Die China-Kinesen können nicht richtig abkürzen.
Ähm, LOG Acquire.
Und was?
LOG Acquire gibt ein Bool zurück.
Dann sollten wir vielleicht doch auch mal checken, ob da True zurückkommt, bevor wir weitermachen.
Sensor Endpoint, da muss rein Sensor ID vermutlich, hoffe ich mal.
Measured Value, das heißt nicht, das heißt Converted Temperature.
So, und jetzt sollte der eigentlich kontinuierlich per ZigBee neue Tastatursachen nach Home Assistant schicken.
Also noch.
Haben wir in Home Assistant.
Minus 327 Grad.
So, habe ich hier alles drin.
Create Task, Sensor, Delay.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, das crasht jetzt nicht und das kompiliert und das tut und macht.
Das sollte jetzt gleich in ZigBee die Temperaturen updaten.
Postchamp?
Das hat doch das letzte Mal schon funktioniert.
Habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Was?
Was ist hier Sensor Endpoint?
Sensor Endpoint?
10.
Ja doch, ist doch richtig.
23 ist Funst.
Easy.
BIKUNEEE!
Ja.
Es überträgt, okay.
Leute, ich beweise es euch noch mal.
Ich setze mich noch mal drauf auf den Sensor.
So, ich sitze.
Ich weiß nicht, was für ein Update Intervall.
Okay, jede Sekunde irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht, was für ein Update Intervall dieses ZigBee Zeug hat.
Ist das Hyperland?
Nein.
Das ist i3.
Das ist 100 Jahre älter als Hyperland und läuft dafür auch gescheit in der VM.
Was Hyperland nicht richtig macht.
Mal kurz Nachtisch mir reinhauen.
Während wir hier dem Sensor beim Risen zugucken.
Ja, da riset er der Sensor.
27,8 haben wir schon.
Mein Hintern ist warm heute.
Hypergachi.
Eindeutig funktioniert das mit dem Set in der Temperatur.
Weil, eben hatten wir noch 20 und jetzt haben wir über 30, seitdem ich drauf hocke.
Ich glaube gar nicht mal, dass Home Assistant langsam ist.
Ich vermute, dass es an meiner Config hier liegt.
Ja, mit dem Intervall und sowas.
Ich habe nur keine...
Default Minimum Reporting Intervall.
Was bedeutet eine 1 hier an der Stelle?
Man weiß es nicht.
In welcher Einheit ist das? Minuten?
Jede Minute?
Was bedeutet eine 1?
Keine Ahnung.
Noch viel interessanter.
Was bedeutet Delta U16 gleich 100?
Ah.
Wie viel sich das changen kann von einer Nachricht zur nächsten?
Ja gut, dass ich da 100 reingeschrieben habe.
Das wird nie der Fall sein.
Guck mal, 32,9 Grad schon.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das funktioniert doch wirklich ausgesprochen gut, oder?
Da kann man sich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Also, und...
Und dazu kommt...
Das ist sogar noch halbwegs lesbar.
Warum ist der Graph bei minus 330 Grad?
Weil mein Sensor initial mal bei minus 330 Grad war.
Das war der Default-Wert aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Aber guck...
Jetzt...
Jetzt geht er...
Geht er wieder hoch.
Der hat minus 330 Grad reported.
Senior Zigbee Developer.
Ja.
Gleich LinkedIn-Profil updaten.
So ist richtig.
Auf LinkedIn ist ja auch jeder gefühlte zweite CEO.
So nach dem Motto CEO von der Mülltonne vor meinem Haus.
Aber Hauptsache CEO.
So funktioniert das doch, ja.
Wie sagen sie immer?
Fake it till you make it.
Das ist nur Zigbee ohne MQTT to Zigbee.
Ja.
Richtig.
Zigbee to MQTT müssen wir auch noch ausprobieren.
Weil das eigentlich meine bevorzugte Variante ist, Zigbee-Geräte einzubinden.
Also, Leute.
Ich bin begeistert, wie easy das war.
Seinen eigenen Zigbee-Temperatursensor mit dem Espressif-Zeug zu entwickeln.
224 Zeilen.
Und...
Ey.
Verhältnismäßig lesbar.
Okay.
Ein paar Sachen habe ich auch noch ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen aufgehübscht.
Oder?
Was sagt ihr?
Kann man schon nicht bestätigen.
Ja.
Kann man schon nicht beschweren.
Habe ich schon deutlich Schlimmeres gesehen.
Könnte vielleicht den Kram noch aus...
Ausgliedern.
Oh, Leute.
Ich habe eine richtig ekle Idee.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen.
Damit ich die Logausgabe nur an einer Stelle schreiben muss...
Ihr wisst, worauf das rausläuft, oder?
Gucke, ob das funktioniert.
Ab came...
Ne, hat schon wieder gebackt
Hat schon wieder gebackt, lull
Ah, weil das Return da drunter steht
Das Return muss da drüber stehen
Siehst du, direkt die Probleme von GoTo gleich mal
Wieder demonstriert
Ne, der ist hier rausgelaufen
Und dann da unten reingelaufen, wo er überhaupt nicht hin soll
Deswegen hat er das jetzt mehrfach ausgegeben
Siehst du, wieder GoTo-Shit
Direkt live
Praktisch, Praxis, Beispiel
Demonstriert
Warum GoTo eine schlechte Idee ist
Chat, erlaubt ihr mir
GoTo zu benutzen an der Stelle
Dass ich nur einmal die Log-Ausgabe schreiben muss
Ich meine, man könnte das
Einfach auch in eine Funktion packen, ja
Man könnte
Man könnte auch einfach sagen
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Log
Zigbee
Info oder sowas
Und das dann da reinpacken
Und
Das einmal hier aufrufen
Und einmal hier aufrufen
Das geht auch, ja
Ist vielleicht die schönere Variante
Anstatt dazu GoToon
So, Funst
Funst, ausgesprochen gut
Ich bin begeistert
So, ähm
Was gibt's denn jetzt noch, was wir ausprobieren müssen
Zigbee to MQTT
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne
Was ganz wichtig ist
Müssen wir noch machen
Und zwar
Partitionstabelle
Partitionstabelle ist die Beispiel-Partitionstabelle
Die ist aber ziemlicher Schrott
Weil die gar nicht
Mein komplette, kompletten
Guck mal, die sind bloß
900k
Also im Prinzip
Verschwende ich gerade
4 Megabit, äh, 3 Megabyte
Von meinem Flash-Speicher
Den könnte ich nicht benutzen
Finde ich nicht
Vielleicht sollten wir für OTA noch eine zweite Partition
Also, so ist die Partitionstabelle kacke
Ich hoffe es gibt irgendwelche
Partition-Generator
Oder sowas
Sowas da vielleicht
Okay, ich hoffe, ich hoffe das taugt, was
Core-Dump, Overrated
Debugging
Solange es First Drive funktioniert, Overrated
Dann machen wir doch mal
Machen wir mal eine eigene Partitionstabelle
Mein Flash ist
4 MB
Das ist richtig
Das können wir tatsächlich sogar so lassen
Zur Lautstärkeregelung der Einzelanwendung
Tatsächlich sowas würde ich mir nicht selbst bauen
So, Partition Table
Also, was ist das erste, was wir brauchen?
NVS
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es NVS heißen muss
Data, Type, oder was?
Data, NVS
900, wunderbar
Das lassen wir mal Default, da weiß ich nämlich nicht
So, das nächste ist
Die Komponente
Das lassen wir mal Default, da weiß ich nämlich nicht
So, das nächste ist
PyInit
Isdata
Das kriegt
Lassen wir auch mal Default
Ja
Warte mal
Size
OK
f00
Size 100
OK
Ich hab keine Ahnung was das genau ist
So, und jetzt kommt die Partitions
Die Partitions
für die
eigentliche
Firmware. Die muss, glaube ich,
auf Factory heißen, sonst
backt das rum.
Offset an 1000 oder an 10.000.
So, und jetzt
will ich
eigentlich meinen kompletten Flash,
kann man das auch in Bytes schauen, ja.
Jetzt will ich eigentlich meinen kompletten
Flash da reinpacken.
Also, 3, 0, 0.
Alter, what? What?
Leute, ich tippe gerade, ich tippe
3, 0?
The fuck? Was ist das
für ein Editor? Macht der einen Hex
oder was? Alter, was ist
das für ein Schrott?
1, 1, 1, 1, 1,
1, okay. Hä?
8.
5.
6. Ich hab
keine Ahnung. Aber ist nicht mehr
viel Platz. Ich hab
den Editor immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Aber ein bisschen Platz, ein bisschen
Platz müssen wir noch lassen, nämlich
für
ZB-Storage, das muss 16k sein
und ZB-Fucked.
ZB-Fucked.
Brauch 1 Kilo Byte
noch. Also,
16k.
Also, lassen wir, machen wir mal so,
okay. Und jetzt
brauchen wir noch
ZB-Storage.
Fat. Okay, Fat.
Pepo, Fat.
16k.
Und jetzt
ZB-Fucked. Muss wahrscheinlich
auch Data-Fat sein.
Und das kriegt die Verbleibenden. Okay.
Wir haben eine eigene
Partitionstabelle gebaut. Partitions.csv.
Von Downloads
Partitions
Ich speichere mir das mal kurz
zwischen. Partitions
hier hin.
Partitions
E
Ja.
Das ist die neue.
Die flashen wir jetzt mal.
Jetzt sollte ich nämlich einfach
meinen kompletten Flash-Speicher benutzen können
für Firmware und nicht irgendwie
nur ein Drittel.
Oh, er muss neu
kompilieren.
Warum auch immer die Partitions-Tabelle
das Neukompilieren
des gesamten Projektes braucht,
man weiß es nicht.
Aber das Ding kompiliert gerne mal neu
zwischendurch.
Was macht eigentlich mein Home Assistant?
Ist der noch am updaten?
Ja. Okay.
35 Grad ist es unter meinem Poppes.
Unter. Wohlgemerkt.
Also das kommt gut hin,
denke ich.
Er flasht. Flash-Champ.
Und es funktioniert.
Joint-Fail.
Ach so. Ja. Ich dab.
Mit dem Neu-Partitionieren
ist ja auch
die bestehenden ZigBee-Daten
auf dem Gerät gelöscht worden.
Das heißt, ich muss es nochmal neu pairen.
Okay. Das war natürlich
jetzt ein bisschen doof.
Devices.
Schmeißen wir den mal weg.
Remove. Okay.
Add Device.
Guck mal.
Es ist geil, wie gut
das funktioniert.
Ich hab
nix gesagt.
Er ist angeblich gejoint, aber das Gerät taucht
nicht auf. Vielleicht hätte ich das...
Ja, vielleicht hätte ich das Gerät
nicht löschen dürfen. Jetzt ist er...
Jetzt ist er hart am rumbanken, glaube ich.
Okay.
Äh. Da gibt's nur eins.
Erase Flash.
Benutzt du ZigBee to MQTT?
Nein. Benutze ich nicht.
Das probieren wir jetzt aber aus
mit ZigBee to MQTT gleich.
Ich hab...
Okay. Ist er fertig? Flaschen.
Äh. While.
Ja. Ist nix mehr drauf. Und jetzt
Flash-Champ.
Nochmal neu die Firma drauf klatschen.
Jetzt sollte es eigentlich...
Jetzt sollte es eigentlich wieder gehen.
Joining ZigBee Network.
Hä? Ach ja.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ey, die Logik. Die Logik
muss ich nicht verstehen, aber es scheint zu funktionieren.
35,4 Grad haben wir.
Er hat's gecheckt.
Mein Gerät ist wieder da.
Wisst ihr, was ich super weird finde?
Wie man das hier schreiben muss.
Sensor, Vendor, Sensor,
Name. Davor muss
aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
äh...
0,9 als Byte stehen.
Da gibt's
hier auch eine Erklärung
für, warum das so sein muss.
Und zwar...
Manufacturer.
The string should be started with
the length of its own. Also sprich...
Das hier,
die Länge, in Byte
als Prefix.
Wisst ihr, ich fand ja...
Ich war ja noch nie ein großer Fan von 0,9.
Aber irgendwie hat sich die halbe Welt
auf 0 terminiertes Strings geeinigt.
Oder was ist die halbe Welt?
99% der Welt haben sich auf 0 terminiertes Strings geeignet.
Warum muss das denn jetzt
prefixed werden mit der Länge?
Das ist sehr unintuitiv.
Stimmt das denn überhaupt?
Espressif hat
1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8,
9.
9?
Und es ist 0B?
B ist 11 in Hex.
Die wissen auch nicht, was sie machen, oder?
1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9.
Selbst wenn ich das hier mitzähle,
komme ich nicht
auf 11.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ich meine, meins stimmt.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7.
Warum habe ich da 0,9 hingeschrieben,
wenn es... Hä?
Ach so!
Ich dachte, dass es davor noch mal 2 Byte braucht.
Nein, die Anführungszeichen zählen sicherlich nicht mit.
Aber die Länge
zählt selbst damit...
Alter, das ist ja so
ultra weird, Mann!
Dann sind es noch mal 11, wenn das mit reinkommt.
Es sind immer 2 mehr als...
Das ist ja... Hä?
Wer hat sich denn das ausgedacht, Mann?
Kann man die Dinger nicht einfach 0 terminaten und gut ist?
Wobei...
Chatge, mal an die C-Kenner eine Frage.
Wenn ich das so schreibe,
dann ist das automatisch ein 0-terminierter String, oder?
Also hier ist hinten dran
tatsächlich noch ein versteckter
0, oder?
Deswegen ist es auch 9.
Es ist einmal hier das spezielle Zeichen,
dann 7 davon
und nochmal die 0.
Was ja auch heißen würde,
Chatge, mal kurz, mal kurz,
um meine Theorie zu überprüfen,
dass hier,
müsste jetzt Länge 1 sein, weil 0 terminiert.
Ja, korrekt.
Leere String ist Länge 1, weil 0 terminiert.
Ja, dann stimmt 9.
Was ich da eingetragen habe. Das ist richtig.
Weil,
es ist 0, es sind
Zeichen plus, plus...
Ist halt die Frage, ob das hier mitgezählt wird, ne?
Was meint ihr?
Wird das mitgezählt, oder wird das nicht mitgezählt selbst?
Ich mein, laut... Ey, das ist so...
laut... Ey, das ist super, so probiert...
ZigBee Manufacturer Prefix Bytes String.
Ich google mal irgendwas.
Okay.
Bei, bei Tuya kommen wir da raus.
Manufacturer Name.
The value of the attribute is 16 bytes in length.
Okay.
Das ist Tuya, ein, äh, Spitz, Spezialitäten.
Okay, keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Wir lassen es einfach mal so.
Und wir hoffen, dass es, äh, so geht.
So.
Jetzt checke ich das Ganze nochmal schnell mit ZigBee to MQTT, wie das hier funktioniert.
Dazu sollten wir
die Home Assistant ZigBee Integration...
Ja, wir sollten mal MQTT configuren, gut.
Die Home Assistant Configuration hauen wir mal raus.
Wie kann ich denn das jetzt wieder entfernen?
ZigBee...
Äh, delete.
Äh, ich glaube, ich muss das vorher...
Kann ich das nicht noch überschreiben lassen?
Ich, ich muss einmal die Settings nochmal überschreiben lassen, dass sich das Ding nicht, nicht wieder anmeldet.
Ja, delete.
Okay, ich formatier das, ich formatier das Ding nochmal, den Stick.
Äh, Home Assistant MQTT ZigBee Add-on.
Das muss man erstmal hinzufügen, genau.
Can be installed here.
Äh, das braucht man, alles klar.
Ich bevorzuge ZigBee to MQTT versus die Standard Home Assistant ZigBee Geschichte, weil die mehr Geräte unterstützen und ich damit weniger, weniger Probleme erwarte.
Ich habe die ZigBee Home Assistant Integration nie ausgiebig getestet, weil ich schon ganz lange auf ZigBee to MQTT bin und keinen Grund sehe, das umzusteigen.
Auf Home Assistant, let's go.
Wir können schon mal das Add-on installieren.
Übrigens, es gibt einen coolen Shortcut in Home Assistant, drückt einfach C, wenn ihr im Web Interface seid.
Dann habt ihr so eine, so ein Command Panel, wie, bisschen wie in Visual Studio Code.
Und da kommt man deutlich schneller mit hin, anstatt in diesem rumgeclicke Navigiere.
So, ZigBee.
Genau, und E, um Geräte und sowas zu, ja, zu suchen.
Hier, ZigBee to MQTT wollen wir installieren, install.
Okay, Finish.
Ja, wunderbar.
Die Devices.
Alter.
Ich habe gesagt, du sollst neu anfangen und nicht sich, du sollst hier nicht das Gerät merken, Mann.
Kack, Kack-Noob.
MonkaS, Alter.
Okay, ich löscht es jetzt.
Delete.
So, und jetzt machen wir das Ganze mit ZigBee, ZigBee to MQTT.
Wir müssen das Gerät einmal resetten.
Damit es sich versucht neu anzumelden.
No, no network found.
Ja, wunderbar.
Der sollte jetzt eigentlich immer weitermachen mit.
Macht er nicht.
No network found.
Ach ne, da macht er nicht weiter.
Ja.
Da muss ich ihn wohl nochmal resetten.
Erase Flash.
Bam.
Okay.
Configuration.
Wie Confi...
ZigBee to MQTT Addon Home Assistant.
Ja.
Der hat einen Button.
Der hat aber nur einen Boot und einen Reset Button.
Der hat keinen Button, den ich irgendwie speziell konfigurieren könnte.
Das wäre praktisch.
Aber ich konfiguriere das Ding genau einmal und ich ändere eh nie meinen ZigBee Key.
Aha, Port muss man da reinschreiben.
Okay.
Ne.
Oh.
Bei Serial?
Oder?
Serial.
Safe.
Ja.
Invalid.
Header.
Flash.
Okay.
So.
Jetzt starten wir mal das Addon.
Zack.
Ich hoffe das funktioniert mit dem Stick, dass ich nicht rebooten muss.
Der Herzmann.
ESP32 Flaschen aus WSL.
GZ.
Mit Rust.
Ah.
Ich sehe schon.
Krustentier Enjoyer am Start.
Backfly.
Danke für den Zap.
Habe ich glaube übersehen.
Z.
Zatch.
MQTT habe ich schon am Start.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Open Web UI.
Okay.
Er hat noch nichts.
Er hat noch nichts gefunden.
Join failed.
Alles klar.
Dann.
Permit.
Join.
Hoffentlich joint er jetzt auch.
Aha.
Joined.
Oh.
Das Ding hat Probleme mit meinen komischen.
Guck mal.
Hier.
Guck mal hier.
Das mag er nicht.
Seht ihr es?
Er ist PC6.
Das mag er nicht.
Mit diesen komischen.
Der denkt der String ist länger als er eigentlich.
Also zählt es doch nicht mit.
Leute.
Dann zählt das doch nicht mit.
Dann hat Espressif da in ihrem Tutorial Mist stehen.
Dann ist das hier 8.
Weil das Prefix selber nicht mit zählt.
Okay.
Wie kriege ich denn den jetzt.
Oh.
Das wurde ein Super Instrument.
Hast du denkt man.
Hatte ich noch surface.
Wehen und was muss man da draufnehmen?
Ah Entschuldigung.
Da wäre der Daumen drauf easiest zu schicken.
Neeein...
Mhm.
Letzten Ruf.
Okay.
Ja okay.
Wir haben das hier.
Ah.
Oh.
Was hút mir пока noch pessoas?
Das war also ein ...
Mit.
über, wir haben das Gerät jetzt über
ZigBee
ZigBee2MQTT drin.
Ja, nur das Dumme ist, dass das Ding
so kacke heißt hier mit
Also ich glaube,
das ist einfach einmal zu
viel. Samuel, danke für den
Sub, was ich nicht schon
gesagt habe. Wenn ich das Gerät
jetzt flashe, nochmal
komplett leer mache
und entferne
aus
aus ZigBee2MQTT
Ich muss das mal hier
anpinnen. Wenn ich das
hier raus entferne
und danach nochmal neu aufnehme
checkt der dann,
dass das Gerät
Hallo?
Pale to remove device
Ja, das macht ja schon mal Bock.
Force removing
Wie Force remove
ich denn? So? Ah, hier.
Force remove. Bam!
Du wurdest
Force removed.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Weg damit. So, der flasht immer noch
auf
Factory Settings
Ja, das ist die Frage. Muss man 0 nicht mit angeben
oder das Prefix? Wir werden es jetzt
sehen. Ich hab jetzt ja, ich hab 8
drin anstatt 9. Sollte das
jetzt, sollte das weggehen.
Alter, ist er heute nochmal fertig mit Flaschen?
Was flasht denn der da so lang?
Auch 4 MB sind
schnell geflasht. Aha,
fertig.
Okay, Invalid Header.
Das ist nicht USB 2.
Ah, das Ding ist sogar USB 3.
Aber, mal davon abgesehen, das hat nur
also, das ist ja immer noch
seriell, also.
So, Permit Join.
Sollte er sich wieder
anmelden?
Joined.
Alter, ich glaube, der hat
es nicht gelöscht.
Der hat es nicht gelöscht, richtig.
Ich könnte wetten, wenn das jetzt zum ersten Mal
joinen würde, wäre das ja alles gut.
Wie kriege ich denn mein
ZigBee Stick komplett resettet?
Moment. Flash.
Wir flashen das nochmal. Nein, nein, nein.
Flash. Nochmal das, das
Erase Flash. Äh, ich hab
nen Sonoff ZigBee
Stick Reset.
Wie resettet man den komplett?
To Reset?
Was, Wireless Switch Stick?
Reset. Ja,
wie geht das? Oh, vielleicht
soll ich das, soll ich machen. Ähm,
ich bin mir unsicher, ob
das so eine gute Idee ist, das zu löschen.
Aber wisst ihr, was wir machen können?
Wir Jibaden das Teil einfach.
Wir machen das
Addon aus. Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Addon aus. Mein Home Assistant
kann es ja anscheinend. So.
Wir stoppen das Addon.
Wir gehen in die Home Assistant
Integration.
Fügen dort
den ZigBee Stick hinzu.
Und sagen neues Netzwerk. Dann löscht
er das. Dann schmeißen wir es in Home Assistant
wieder raus. Und dann nehmen wir das Addon.
Dann sollte es geschehen. Ich mein,
aber, da gibt's doch bestimmt was,
was besseres, oder? Reset.
Äh, das ist super
advancer Shit anscheinend. Erase Network
Settings and create a new Network.
Genau. Wenn es
nicht so lahm wäre in Home Assistant,
dann würde ich das deutlich
mehr feiern. Die
ZigBee Integration.
So, ZigBee
MQTT ist aus.
Mein Gerät ist
auch aus. Der meckert jetzt, dass er
keine Firmware drauf hat.
Was auch gut so ist.
Du, du, du, du.
Home Assistant.
Mach hinne.
Du, du,
du, du, du.
Du hast den ESP32 überhaupt nicht.
Lüg nicht rum.
Der ist ja gerade ohne Firmware und
sendet überhaupt nichts.
Der erzählt ja wieder einen Blödsinn.
So, und jetzt delete.
Zack.
Und jetzt gehen wir wieder in das Home Assistant,
in das Addon und starten das.
Und jetzt sollte das, jetzt sollte das
leer sein.
Oh no no, das startet schon
gleich. Oh.
Sag bloß, das ist jetzt kaputt.
Ne, ist einfach nicht gestartet.
Es ist lahm AF.
Der Herz
Mann. Der Herz Mann
ist slow. Herz Mann?
Aha, was?
What?
Wo kommt denn dieses
fucking Device her, Mann? Das ist weg.
Ich hab
das Ding eben gelöscht.
Das Gerät hat nicht mal eine Firmware drauf, Alter.
The fuck?
Okay, ich hab ne Idee, woran das
liegt. Ich glaube,
okay. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Das versucht, das versucht mitzudenken,
Leute. Das ist ne ganz schlechte Idee,
wenn das versucht mitzudenken.
Wir brauchen das, wir brauchen
das Addon für SSH.
Terminal.
Weil da garantiert
noch übrig gebliebene Sachen von dem, von dem
letzten Addon, irgendwelche Caches übrig geblieben sind.
Alter, ist das ein Akt, so nen ZigBee Stick
zu resetten?
Ich werd verrückt.
Nix hier. Configuration.
Passwort. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9.
Highly secure.
130.
Start.
Okay.
SSH
has IO at
130.
Gigant minus R 130.
Okay.
Yes.
So, und ich wette mit euch
unter Home Assistant
ZigBee...
Ja, guck mal, da liegt noch der ganze Shit
vom letzten Mal.
RM minus RF
Sternchen. Bam.
Okay.
So, ich hoffe jetzt
geht's besser.
Oder ich hab's Addon kaputt gemacht, muss das Addon
neu installieren.
So, schauen wir mal.
Okay, da liegt wieder Zeug. Das ist gut.
Der hat's neu initialisiert.
Initialized.
Ich mein, das Gerät
kann offensichtlicherweise gerade nicht
gehen. Das hat keine Firmware drauf.
Okay, nice. Und jetzt
Open Web UI. Wenn das jetzt immer noch da ist,
dreh ich durch. Nein, ist nicht wieder da.
Okay. Flash.
Okay.
Join.
Wenn es jetzt
falsch heißt, hab ich keinen Bock mehr.
Dann kann, dann lebe ich
halt mit dem
äh, mit dem Fragezeichen und dem
nicht richtigen
Namen dran.
Äh, Join ZigBee.
Ah, jetzt
heißt es richtig.
Okay.
Jetzt heißt es richtig, alles klar.
Okay, nice.
Heißt im Endeffekt,
es hat alles
richtig gut funktioniert.
Hier ist das
Device. Dem geben wir jetzt vielleicht auch
einen halbwegs sinnvollen Namen.
Devices.
Was, Model ist
auto-generated?
Echt? Warum?
Das Model steht doch da drinne.
Ist überhaupt nicht auto-generated,
das Model. Laber nicht.
Ist genauso, wie es drinnen
steht. Okay, umbenennen
würdest du in ZigBee to MQTT, ja.
Die Frage ist nur, wie?
Friendly Name. Das würde ich
gerne umbenennen, ja. Ach, hier.
Ja, dann nennen wir das jetzt
mal, äh, ja.
Fischteich.
Hä, hallo?
Ich kann das
nicht ändern. Muss man
das noch irgendwie einschalten?
Wie ändert
man das? Edit?
Aha.
Update Home Assistant
Entity ID. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sinniger. Fischteich.
Ist ja eh nur zum testen.
ESP.
Könnte es auch so nennen.
Fischteichtemp. Okay.
Wow. Way to
dank. Hat
umbenannt. Temperature
is unknown.
Ist irgendwie broken. Obwohl der
eigentlich die Temperatur updaten sollte hier.
Ich glaub, ich glaub wir haben
es irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt gemacht.
Mit dem umbenennen.
Weil hier, ne, das checkt das.
Das es 35,6 Grad
ist. Ach, jetzt hat
das, okay.
Ja. 35,68
Grad.
Link quality. Ach, das
kapiert er jetzt auch.
Was ist MQTT select?
Hängt das denn an einem Akku?
Wenn ja, wäre die Spannung nicht interessant. Aktuell
nicht. In Zukunft schon. Und ja,
genau da hast du recht. Ja.
Das steht auch noch auf dem Plan.
Dass wir das mal batterietauglich
fit machen.
Ich habe ein Board, was im Deep Sleep
fast nix braucht. Nur
Mikroampere. Das heißt,
wenn das 4 Stunden Deep Sleept,
dann misst's. Verschickt. Und wenn
der Deep Sleept, hält das
2 Jahre an.
Bei 1.200
Milliamperestunden.
An einem 1.200
Milliamperestunden Akku.
Und das ist schon recht großzügig
gerechnet. Aber praktisch wird's wahrscheinlich trotzdem
ein bisschen weniger sein. Wobei,
doch, kommt hin. Das ist ja in Wirklichkeit sogar so ein
2.000 Milliamperestunden Akku. Hab ich gerade
gesehen. Wusste ich auch nicht, dass der so groß ist.
Ja, nice. Übrigens, Leute. Wem so Streams
gefallen, bisschen Sellout muss sein.
Ja, ich freue mich selbstverständlich
nicht nur über Subs, sondern auch über Follows.
Das heißt, wer in Zukunft
wieder mit am Start sein will,
kann mir gerne jetzt
folgen. Sellout beendet.
Ich mag eh viel zu wenig
Sellout, gell.
Das Subscriben ist natürlich auch super.
Dankeschön, Lucky.
Alter, mein Poppus
ist richtig hot. 36 Grad.
So.
Ich setz mich mal wieder runter
vom Sensor.
Guck, schon wird's kühler. Schon wird's kühler.
Schon wird's kühler.
Kaum hab ich mich runtergesetzt
vom Sensor. Sehr
nice.
Ja.
Ich hab drauf gesessen. Also, das war die Temperatur
von meinem Hintern hier. Knapp 36 Grad.
Also, ich hab kein Fieber
oder so, wie's aussieht.
Bits. Ja, dankeschön.
10 Milliarden Bits.
Leute, gestern war ich 3 Stunden Fahrradfahren.
Ich merk's heut immer.
Und heut Morgen noch, heut Morgen nochmal
eine halbe Stunde so entspannungsmäßig
eine Runde rennen. Das ist echt.
Ich merk's immer noch richtig hart in den Beinen von gestern.
Drei Stunden ist echt...
Auf mehr hätte ich echt keinen Bock.
So.
Ja, Temperatur geht runter.
Er hat keine Statistics. Wir haben's
mit dem Umbenennen, glaub ich, kaputt gemacht.
Ach, das checkt er. Okay.
Also, die Graphen in Home Assistant
sind grausam, ey. Ich mag das
überhaupt nicht. Das ist super hakelig. Auch
hier die Zeitauswahl und sowas.
Jo. Ich glaube,
das war's für heute, oder? Ach, nee.
Was ich nochmal gucken wollt, hier. ESP32.
Firebeetle.
Battery.
Voltage. Ich nenn's mal trotzdem
Battery. Ob man das...
Ob die da irgendeinen Pin haben
oder so, wo man das abfragen kann.
Das ist das alte Board.
Mit dem normalen ESP32.
Der Output
Voltage of the Pin VCC
Sequel to Power Source.
Man kann das bestimmt
auslesen.
Voltage. VIN.
Oder muss ich da
ein Kabel legen?
Battery. Charge. Read.
Okay. Na, die machen das
selbst, ja. Ja.
Die packen
tatsächlich den
offenen GPIO
und machen dann Analog-Digital-
Converter und gucken, wie viel Spannung
anlegt. Es gibt anscheinend echt
nichts eingebautes.
Moment. Es ist angeblich schon
was connected.
Ja, ist klar. Da kämpf ich mich jetzt ganz
bestimmt durch, ja.
ESP32. C6.
Gmatix.
Weil ich ja genau der Richtige für
Energydrinks bin, ja.
Vielleicht hat das auch schon irgendeinen GPIO-Pin, wo
das standardmäßig drauf ist.
Wo man das auslesen kann.
Hier lest ihr...
Hier kommt die Batterie.
Vielleicht hat das schon was.
Das hab ich übrigens vorhin gesucht und nicht gefunden.
Ist das irgendwo schon angeschlossen?
Ich seh da jetzt nix.
Ja, guckt.
Hier drüber könnte man beispielsweise
Solar-Panels anschließen, die automatisch
die Batterie laden, weil das Ding Lade-Elektronik
hat. Das ist für
Displays. Brauch ich nicht.
Wobei es eigentlich richtig
nice ist, da drüber Displays anzuschließen.
Viel angenehmer, als diesen ganzen
Krempel über GPIOs anzustöpseln.
Ja, das guck ich mir jetzt bestimmt
nicht an. Also GPIO
36 ist connected
zu...
Das ist bei dem anderen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es bei dem auch so ist.
Aber vielleicht.
Battery, Voltage...
IO0? Wo hast du das gelesen?
Wenn man kaum wüsste, war man ordentlich
lesen.
IO0.
Meinen die damit...
Was ja schon mal Sinn macht, weil das nicht
nach draußen geführt ist.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Testen wir einfach mal, oder?
Testen wir mal.
Im Prinzip brauchen wir dann nichts hiervon.
Nichts davon.
Machen wir einfach jetzt hier.
Analog
Read.
Ich... Boah.
Ich hab lange nichts mehr gelesen mit Arduino.
Ähm...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da im Vorfeld
irgendwas machen muss.
Da musste man doch irgendwie Pin Mode oder sowas
noch einstellen. Oder auch nicht?
Ich bilde mir ein, man musste...
Was ist A0? Pin Mode.
Ja, Pin Mode, genau.
Pin Mode.
GPIO 0.
Oh ne, wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal?
Mode.
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung. Ist schon zu daher.
Output. Input. Okay.
Input.
Und jetzt Analog Read.
GPIO 0.
Schauen wir mal.
Log. Logger.
Info.
Äh, was kommt denn da zurück?
Ein...
U16. Okay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wenn das funktioniert.
Out of the Box wäre
Extremely Pog.
Also was auch immer das ist,
das ergibt jetzt
wenig Sinn.
Was ich interessant finde, ist, dass es schon
relativ konstant
der gleiche Wert ist.
Der möchte mir schon irgendwas sagen.
Ich meine, aktuell bin ich ja auch über
USB dran.
Aktuell bin ich über USB dran.
Deswegen hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
dass glatt 3,3 Volt rauskommt.
An der Stelle.
Weil das ja umgewandelt wird von USB in...
Jetzt müsste man jetzt echt mal mit einer Batterie testen.
Unsigned ins...
Ja.
Ich kann den Pin
nirgendswohin schließen. Der Pin wird nicht rausgeführt.
Den man...
Das kann schon sein, dass man sich den auch umrechnen muss.
Jaja.
Das ist schon richtig.
Genau.
Du hast Recht.
Das ist der Analog-Digital-Converter-Wert.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung,
was da rauskommen kann.
Gibt es hier irgendwas?
Da muss man bestimmt noch was einstellen.
ADC, Arduino.
Da kann man bestimmt noch irgendwie Precision
oder sowas.
Ja genau.
Da ist das Eingangspin.
P32
ADC
Battery.
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Ich würde sagen,
dass dieser Wert,
dass mit Volt dahinter kann man verändern,
dass dieser Wert jetzt ziemlich genau 3,3 Volt entspricht.
Aber die Frage ist,
wie der Verlauf ist.
Okay, was ist, wenn man auf
Resolution 12 wechselt?
Das ist jetzt einfach nur geraten.
Kommt im Prinzip
genau das gleiche raus.
Ja, da weiß ich jetzt nicht,
wie man das umrechnet.
Keine Ahnung.
Das muss man jetzt...
Okay.
Pfeifert. Okay.
Pfeifert. Okay. What?
Okay.
Also, was soll
ich machen? Analog Reading
mal Referenz-Voltage.
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Was ist denn meine Referenz-Voltage?
Alter, wie ich
meinen Plan habe?
Aha. Basic Tutorial.
Da gibt es sogar einen Guide zu.
Ich kack nur.
Voltage Calculation.
Wie wäre es, einfach mal in den Guide zu gucken?
Hier. Bam.
Die machen hier nichts, ne?
Ah, die sagen Analog Resolution
12.
Okay. Ja, das mache ich jetzt auch.
Alle
Read GPIO 0.
Äh.
Das gibt einfach gar nichts aus.
Serial Printline. Ja, das funzt ja nicht
bei mir gescheit.
Das muss ich ändern.
Logger. Log Info.
Das Serial Printline
ist ein bisschen broken.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was da
rauskommt. Also, ich vermute
3,3.
Äh.
Die Ausgabe funzt nicht.
Ah, ist das ein Float?
Was da rauskommt?
Das ist schlecht.
Ich habe den Float Support für das Formatting
ausgeschaltet.
Oh, ne. Okay.
Ich dachte, ich muss keine Floats
formatieren.
Ich dachte, ich kann ein bisschen Flash-Speicher sparen.
Okay. Print. Print.
Dann Print F'en wir das jetzt.
Okay. Print F.
Was ist denn ein Float?
F. Ah.
Okay. Wir haben 5,4.
Das liegt daran, weil es
per USB angeschlossen ist.
Macht ja auch Sinn.
Trotzdem mit 3,3.
Wie kommt der hier auf diese Magic
Nummer?
Sollten es nicht 5 sein?
Das ist die Rev Voltage. Aber woher weiß man das?
Man muss es halt einfach wissen.
Aber nice, dass das funktioniert
mit dem Batterieladen.
Da können wir das nächste Mal weitermachen an der Stelle.
Das nächste Mal
bauen wir das ein bisschen um.
Auf Deep Sleep und
Batteriebetrieb.
Nice.
Excellent.
Ziehen wir das mal raus.
Und heben den Controller auf,
dass ich nicht drüberfalle.
Alles klar Chat.
Schön, dass so viele dabei waren.
Über 3 Stunden Bastelstelz.
Wird mal wieder Zeit.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Handleak. Nochmal zum Schluss.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Bis dann. See you.